Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is, the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 restishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。没错，就是 restishistory.com。本期节目由 SAP 赞助播出。随着投资者、客户和员工对您的业务提出更高要求，
it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs, Connect with new suppliers and manage payroll even when your business is being pulled in different directions to deliver a quality product at a fair price while paying your people what they're worth too so your business can stay unfazed. Learn more at SAP.com slash uncertainty.
是时候尝试 SAP 了。其人工智能驱动的功能可以帮助您精简成本、对接新供应商并管理工资发放，即使您的业务在多方压力下仍需以合理的价格提供优质产品，同时还要确保员工获得应有的报酬，从而让您的业务保持从容不迫。欲了解更多信息，请访问 SAP.com/uncertainty。
You know what's better than the one big thing? Two big things. Exactly. The new iPhone 17 Pro on TELUS's five-year rate plan price lock. Yep, it's the most powerful iPhone ever, plus more peace of mind with your bill. over five years. This is big. Get the new iPhone 17 Pro at tellus.com slash iPhone 17 Pro on select plans. Conditions and exclusions
你知道什么比一件大事更好吗？两件大事。没错。TELUS 五年期费率锁定计划下的全新 iPhone 17 Pro。没错，这是有史以来最强大的 iPhone，加上五年内账单更省心。这可是件大事。请在 tellus.com/iphone17pro 上选择指定套餐购买全新 iPhone 17 Pro。适用条件和排除条款。
apply. Today on The Rest is History, we are visiting Disneyland and we are exploring the backstory of theme parks because Dominant, you love a theme park, don't you? So I actually do because I'm an adrenaline junkies, you know, Tom. So I really enjoy doing this episode. And actually, the deeper we went into it, the more fascinating it is. So you know the first roller coasters? Zaris, Russia, the age of Catherine the Great, surfs building great hills of ice and aristocrats going to boggaining down them. And then you get into the 19th century, you have gravity
今天在《历史的余味》中，我们将造访迪士尼乐园，探索主题公园的背景故事。多米尼克，你很喜欢主题公园，对吧？我确实很喜欢，因为我是个肾上腺素成瘾者，你知道的，汤姆。所以我真的很享受制作这一期节目。事实上，我们挖掘得越深，就越觉得它引人入胜。那么，你知道最早的过山车吗？沙皇俄国，叶卡捷琳娜大帝时代，农奴们建造巨大的冰山，贵族们坐着滑下去。然后到了 19 世纪，你有了重力
switchback railroads, people traveling on these kind of mad railways against a painted background. But there's other predecessors to Disneyland, aren't there? So I know you love a Vauxhall Pleasure Garden. Well, yes, because it's nice to know that ultimately the origins of Disneyland lay in South London, where I live. That was a revelation for me. Yeah. Fountains, fireworks, houses made of glass, all that kind of thing. So that's all great.
滑行铁路，人们在这些疯狂的铁路上穿行，背景是手绘的风景。但迪士尼乐园还有其他前身，不是吗？我知道你喜欢沃克斯豪尔游乐园（Vauxhall Pleasure Garden）。嗯，是的，因为很高兴知道迪士尼乐园的起源最终是在我居住的伦敦南区。这对我来说是一个启示。是的。喷泉、烟花、玻璃屋，诸如此类。所以这些都很棒。
And then we end by talking about Disneyland itself. A mad story, actually, when it opened in 1955. Basically, Walt Disney faced one of history's most difficult and most perilous dilemmas. He only had enough water to have drinks, fountains or flushing toilets. And only on this podcast will people find out what he chose. It's an extraordinary episode, great fun, and we hope you enjoy it. Absolutely, we do. This episode is brought to you by Hive.
最后我们来谈谈迪士尼乐园本身。这其实是一个疯狂的故事，它在 1955 年开业时，华特·迪士尼面临着历史上最困难、最危险的困境之一。他当时的水量只够维持饮水喷泉或冲水马桶。只有在本期播客中，大家才能知道他选择了什么。这是一期非凡的节目，非常有趣，希望你们喜欢。当然，我们会的。本期节目由 Hive 赞助。
You know, history is full of transformations. The Romans shifted from Republic to Empire. The Tudors transformed monasteries into country houses. And do you know what? Hive has had one of its own. Everybody knows Hive for smart thermostats, but now they've evolved. into something much greater. Solar panels that help you
你知道，历史充满了变革。罗马人从共和国转变为帝国。都铎王朝将修道院改造成乡村别墅。你知道吗？Hive 也经历了自己的变革。每个人都知道 Hive 的智能恒温器，但现在他们已经进化了。进化成了更伟大的东西。帮助您
to power your home with clean energy, heat pumps that pull warmth from thin air, EV charges that charge your car while you're asleep, all managed through a single app. This is all about giving people the power to transform their homes, from waste to efficiency,
用清洁能源为家庭供电的太阳能电池板，从空气中汲取热量的热泵，在您睡觉时为汽车充电的电动汽车充电桩，所有这些都通过一个应用程序进行管理。这一切都是为了赋予人们改造家庭的能力，从浪费到高效，
from dependence to control, from consumption to contribution. So history's next great transformation may not be happening in parliaments or palaces. It may be happening in your home. A quiet revolution minus guillotine. Hive. Know your power. Visit hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected heat pumps. I, the Prime Minister of the Soviet Union, have come to you as a guest, but I have just been told I cannot go to Disneyland.
从依赖到掌控，从消费到贡献。所以历史的下一次伟大变革可能不会发生在议会或宫殿里。它可能就发生在您的家中。一场没有断头台的静默革命。Hive。掌握您的力量。访问 hivehome.com 了解更多。需视勘测和适用性而定。Hive 应用程序兼容选定的热泵。我，苏联总理，作为客人来到这里，但我刚刚被告知我不能去迪士尼乐园。
Why not, I asked, is it by any chance because you now have rocket launching paths there? No, they told me, you cannot go there because, just listen to this, the American authorities cannot guarantee your safety. What? Has cholera or plague broken out there that I'm, might catch it? Or has Disneyland been seized by bandits who might destroy me? But your policemen are such strong men. Surely they could deal effectively with such bandits. I said I should like to go to Disneyland just the same and see how Americans spend their leisure, but I am told
为什么不呢？我问，难道是因为你们现在那里有火箭发射场吗？不，他们告诉我，你不能去那里，因为，听好了，美国当局无法保证你的安全。什么？那里爆发了霍乱或瘟疫，我可能会感染吗？还是迪士尼乐园被可能摧毁我的强盗占领了？但你们的警察是如此强壮的人。他们肯定能有效地对付这些强盗。我说我还是想去迪士尼乐园看看美国人是如何度过闲暇时光的，但我被告知
it is impossible. This development causes me bitter regret, and I cannot but express my disappointment. So that amazingly was not a South African, although I may have given you that impression. It was in fact a Russian, and specifically Nikita Khrushchev, Premier of the Soviet Union, who was speaking at 20th Century Fox in Los Angeles on the 19th September, 1959, and he was halfway through the first state visit ever made by a Soviet leader to the United States. It was a massive media circus, and when he came to L.A., he wanted Hollywood, the work. So he met Gary Cooper and Elizabeth Taylor and Marilyn Monroe, all the stars. But what his wife, Nina, wanted was to go to Disneyland. Because Dominic, Nina had been a huge fan of
这是不可能的。这一事态发展令我深感遗憾，我不得不表达我的失望。所以，令人惊讶的是，那不是南非人，尽管我可能给了你那种印象。事实上，他是一位俄罗斯人，具体来说是苏联总理尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫，他于 1959 年 9 月 19 日在洛杉矶的 20 世纪福克斯公司发表了讲话，当时他正处于苏联领导人对美国进行的首次国事访问的中途。那是一场大规模的媒体马戏团，当他来到洛杉矶时，他想要好莱坞，想要一切。所以他见到了加里·库珀、伊丽莎白·泰勒和玛丽莲·梦露，所有的明星。但他的妻子尼娜想去的是迪士尼乐园。因为多米尼克，尼娜自 20 世纪 40 年代以来一直是
Disney films since the 1940s and she'd specifically requested to visit the park. And Walt Disney had agreed to meet them personally, escort them around. But it gets cancelled. Why? So slightly unclear, actually. Some accounts say that there were security concerns in the Los Angeles police. Some say that there were Soviet security concerns, some that the visit was cancelled on the orders of the U.S. State Department. Whatever the truth, and it's really hard to get at the truth, Christoph was furious about it.
迪士尼电影的忠实粉丝，她特别要求参观这个公园。华特·迪士尼也同意亲自迎接他们，并陪同他们参观。但它被取消了。为什么？其实有点不清楚。一些说法称洛杉矶警方有安全顾虑，一些说法称有苏联的安全顾虑，还有一些说法称这次访问是根据美国国务院的命令取消的。无论真相如何，而且真相确实很难查明，赫鲁晓夫对此感到非常愤怒。
And upset. In his memoir, Christchroff remembers in the late 60s, I think it is, early 70s. He talks about this. He draws attention to it, and he says, the visit to Disneyland was cancelled because the American authorities were worried about right-wing, anti-communist demonstration. Of course, the irony is that Walt Disney himself at this point was right-wing and anti-communist. He hated Bolsheviks. Yeah, but he was prepared to welcome Christoph and show him around.
而且很沮丧。在赫鲁晓夫的回忆录中，我想是在 60 年代末或 70 年代初，他提到了这一点。他引起了人们的注意，并说，访问迪士尼乐园被取消是因为美国当局担心右翼的反共示威。当然，讽刺的是，华特·迪士尼本人当时也是右翼和反共的。他讨厌布尔什维克。是的，但他准备欢迎赫鲁晓夫并带他参观。
Anyway, the visit was cancelled. And I thought it was a fun way to set up an episode about Disneyland. If challenging for someone who can't do a Russian accent. Exactly, which is also an attraction. Because this is 1959. Disneyland has only been open for four years. But even at this point, to somebody like Christoph, the Premier of the Soviet Union, Union. Disneyland is an extraordinary draw. It's a symbol of America, as you says, I want to go
总之，访问被取消了。我觉得这是一个开启关于迪士尼乐园节目的有趣方式。对于一个不会说俄语口音的人来说很有挑战性。没错，这也是一个吸引力。因为这是 1959 年。迪士尼乐园才开业四年。但即使在这一点上，对于像赫鲁晓夫这样的苏联总理来说，迪士尼乐园也是一个非凡的吸引力。它是美国的象征，正如他所说，我想去
and see how the American people spend their leisure time. So even at this point in 1959, four years old, it's a symbol of America, of childhood fantasy, of small town, nostalgia, and of kind of mid-century futurism, all the things that we associate with Disneyland today. And people who think, gosh, a history podcast really, I mean, Disneyland is a project conceived in the 1940s, built in the 1950s, in the early Cold War. It's still a hugely important place. It's one of the most visited places on the planet. So if you look at the stats, almost 800 million people have been to Disneyland in the 70 years that it's been open. And if you ask, I would guess, most children in the world, most people under the age of, let's say, I don't know, 15, 13 or something.
看看美国人民是如何度过闲暇时光的。所以即使在 1959 年，也就是它四岁的时候，它也是美国、童年幻想、小镇怀旧和某种世纪中期未来主义的象征，所有这些都是我们今天与迪士尼乐园联系在一起的东西。人们会想，天哪，真的是历史播客吗？我的意思是，迪士尼乐园是一个 20 世纪 40 年代构思、50 年代初在冷战早期建造的项目。它仍然是一个非常重要的地方。它是地球上访问量最大的地方之一。所以如果你看统计数据，在开业的 70 年里，几乎有 8 亿人去过迪士尼乐园。如果你问，我猜，世界上大多数孩子，大多数 15 岁、13 岁以下的人，
What's the one place you would most like to go if you could go anywhere? Disneyland would probably, I guess, be top of the list. I don't think so. Hadrian's War. Yes. There was some interesting chat when we're in at Disneyland with your daughter about your childhood holidays. I think it's fair to say the scars are still quite raw. Anyway, I think it's a really good subject for a history podcast for three reasons. So first of all, because it's a great window into 1950s America,
如果你能去任何地方，你最想去的一个地方是什么？迪士尼乐园可能会排在榜首。我不这么认为。哈德良长城。是的。当我们在迪士尼乐园时，你和你女儿关于你童年假期的谈话很有趣。我认为可以公平地说，伤疤仍然相当新鲜。总之，我认为这是一个非常好的历史播客主题，原因有三。首先，因为它是一个了解 1950 年代美国的绝佳窗口，
into the anxieties and ambitions of Eisenhower's America when it is built. Secondly, I think it's an opportunity for us on the rest of history to dig into the history of things that most people probably don't think of as historical artifacts, which are to say parks, carousels, rides, the first roller coasters under Catherine the Great. I mean, oh, so maybe that's why Christopher wanted to go. It's a great Russian invention. A great Russian invention, exactly. Well, we'll come back to this.
了解艾森豪威尔时代美国在建造它时的焦虑和雄心。其次，我认为这对我们《历史的余味》来说是一个深入挖掘大多数人可能不会认为是历史文物的东西的机会，也就是公园、旋转木马、游乐设施、叶卡捷琳娜大帝统治下的第一批过山车。我的意思是，哦，也许这就是赫鲁晓夫想去的原因。这是一个伟大的俄罗斯发明。一个伟大的俄罗斯发明，没错。好吧，我们稍后再谈这个。
And of course, Disneyland itself is a remarkable thing. For me, and we'll discuss this in the second half, it is one of the most influential architectural creations of the mid-20th century. And of course, because of its whole and on the imagination of so many people, it has become a massive cultural enterprise in its own right, just like Snow White or Mary Poppins or any of the films, Tom, that you talked about in the previous episode. Yeah.
当然，迪士尼乐园本身就是一件非凡的事情。对我来说，我们将在下半部分讨论这一点，它是 20 世纪中期最具影响力的建筑创作之一。当然，由于它对这么多人的想象力的掌控，它已经成为一个巨大的文化企业，就像《白雪公主》或《欢乐满人间》或汤姆你在上一集谈到的任何电影一样。是的。
So to explore where it comes from, let's get back to Disney himself, the guy who you described so brilliant. in Monday's episode. So after the Second World War, as we discussed, really some of the fun has gone out at the Disney studio. The studio, the animators, they've been decimated by the war, and they never really recover. And the great biography by Neil Gablet, he talks about how in the 1940s and in 1950s, there's
所以为了探索它的起源，让我们回到迪士尼本人，那个你在周一的节目中描述得如此精彩的人。所以二战后，正如我们所讨论的，迪士尼工作室确实失去了一些乐趣。工作室、动画师们在战争中损失惨重，他们从未真正恢复过来。尼尔·盖布勒（Neil Gabler）的伟大传记中谈到了 20 世纪 40 年代和 50 年代，有一种
a real sense of Disney losing interest and losing confidence in his animated films. He's quoted as saying to one of his friends, we are through with caviar from now on, it is mashed potatoes and gravy. In other words, everything is going to be a little bit cheaper, a little bit blander, just not as good, basically. And Walt Disney is looking for outlets for this sort of tinkering genius and creative enthusiasm that we described last time. And the most obvious one of these, which plays a huge part at Disneyland and indeed at most modern day theme parks or kind of amusement parks, is trains. So in the summer of 1948, Disney goes with his animator Wally Kimball.
迪士尼对他的动画电影失去兴趣和信心的真实感觉。他曾对一位朋友说，我们不再吃鱼子酱了，从现在开始是土豆泥和肉汁。换句话说，一切都会变得更便宜、更平淡，基本上没那么好。华特·迪士尼正在为我们上次描述的那种修补天才和创造性热情寻找出口。其中最明显的一个，在迪士尼乐园以及大多数现代主题公园或游乐园中发挥了巨大作用，那就是火车。所以 1948 年夏天，迪士尼和他的动画师沃利·金博尔（Wally Kimball）一起去
Of course he's called Wally. Of course he is. To a railroad fare in Chicago for a break. And on the way, they ride on the Santa Fe Railroad, and the people find out that Walt is there, and they say, would you like to ride in the engine and to pull the whistle chord? A very American kind of sound, the whistle of a train.
当然他叫沃利。当然他是。去芝加哥参加一个铁路博览会休息一下。在路上，他们乘坐了圣达菲铁路，人们发现华特在那里，他们说，你想坐在引擎里拉汽笛绳吗？一种非常美国的声音，火车的汽笛声。
And Kimball said that after Walt had done this, he sat there staring into space, smiling and smiling. I had never seen him look so happy. Well, do you know, Dominic, I think trains are wonderful things. And I say that as someone who has officially named a train. You named it the Athelstan, didn't you? The King Athelstan. There was a brilliant photograph.
金博尔说，华特做完这件事后，他坐在那里盯着虚空，不停地微笑。我从未见过他看起来那么快乐。嗯，你知道吗，多米尼克，我认为火车是美妙的东西。我作为一个正式为火车命名的人这么说。你把它命名为“埃塞尔斯坦号”（Athelstan），对吧？埃塞尔斯坦国王号。有一张精彩的照片。
What? Of you looking with a gaggle of sheepish, grey-haired men. There was like some sort of bishop, some priest. I always assume you're going to be hanging around with a priest. And Ed Davy, the leader of the Liberal Democrats. The local MP. Yeah. And they all look like variants of you.
什么？你和一群唯唯诺诺、灰头发的男人在一起。好像有某种主教，某种牧师。我总是假设你会和牧师混在一起。还有埃德·戴维（Ed Davy），自由民主党领袖。当地议员。是的。他们看起来都像你的变体。
which I thought was interesting. I thought it was very amusing. Yeah, but Dominic, when I actually launched the train at King Athelstand to mark the 11th anniversary of the coronation of King Athelstan in Kingston, I was actually surrounded by... Fans? No, by men in chain armour, the local Kingston feared.
我觉得这很有趣。我觉得这非常逗。是的，但多米尼克，当我真正为埃塞尔斯坦国王号火车揭幕以纪念埃塞尔斯坦国王在金斯顿加冕 11 周年时，我实际上被……粉丝包围了？不，是被穿着锁子甲的男人，当地金斯顿的恐惧。
Yeah. And that's quite Disney as well, because there's a lot of dressing up. Okay, well, so Disney's had his own train ride, not on the Athelstan. He goes to Chicago, and this, moment when he goes to this railroad fare is, I think, a transformative moment in his life. He is asked to run some of the old engines, which he does, and he loves that. But also the fair has special exhibits, which are called, some people at the fair call them lands. There's a geyser, there's an Indian village, so Native American village, and there is a replica of the French
是的。那也很有迪士尼风格，因为有很多装扮。好吧，所以迪士尼有他自己的火车之旅，不是在埃塞尔斯坦号上。他去了芝加哥，我认为他去这个铁路博览会的时刻是他生命中的一个转折点。他被要求驾驶一些旧引擎，他照做了，他很喜欢。但博览会也有特别的展览，有些人称之为“乐园”。有一个间歇泉，有一个印第安村庄，也就是美洲原住民村庄，还有一个新奥尔良法国区的复制品。
quarter in New Orleans. So something that you can see effectively at Disneyland. Anyway, he comes back and he's completely obsessed. He buys this massive train set and he fills half of a double garage with it. So he's got two trains, he's got tunnels, he's got bridges, has got all this. Like Rod Stewart? Like Rod Stewart, exactly. Another somebody else who you've hung around with, no? Rod Stewart?
所以你在迪士尼乐园可以有效地看到的东西。总之，他回来了，他完全着迷了。他买了这个巨大的火车模型，并用它填满了双车库的一半。所以他有两列火车，有隧道，有桥梁，有这一切。像罗德·斯图尔特（Rod Stewart）？像罗德·斯图尔特，没错。另一个你曾经混在一起的人，不是吗？罗德·斯图尔特？
Yes, I have met him. This is just a massive name-dropping exercise this show. So then he says, well, a model train's not enough. I want a life-size train. And he actually builds his own life-size train in the Disney studio machine shop. So by Christmas 1948, he's actually organizing test runs on the Disney sound stage of this train that he has built himself. You know, I love that about him. Yeah, it's fun.
是的，我见过他。这个节目简直就是一个巨大的炫耀名字的练习。所以他接着说，好吧，模型火车是不够的。我想要一列真人大小的火车。他实际上在迪士尼工作室的机器车间里建造了他自己的真人大小的火车。所以到 1948 年圣诞节，他实际上正在迪士尼摄影棚组织他自己建造的这列火车的试运行。你知道，我喜欢他这一点。是的，这很有趣。
You know, because we were saying in the previous episode how he didn't really wasn't interested in money. Yeah. But I like to see him spending money in such a wholesome and fun way. I think if I was a billionaire, I would set up a massive train set. So when he buys a new house in the late 1940s, a lot of Hollywood moguls would say, I'd like a massive cinema, I'll have a sort of a sex dungeon or whatever. Would they? Where does that come from?
你知道，因为我们在上一集里说他并不真正关心钱。是的。但我喜欢看到他以如此健康和有趣的方式花钱。我想如果我是亿万富翁，我会建立一个巨大的火车模型。所以当他在 20 世纪 40 年代末买了一栋新房子时，很多好莱坞大亨会说，我想要一个巨大的电影院，我会有一个某种性地牢之类的。他们会吗？那来自哪里？
He says, no, no, no. I must have room for my railroad. And he spends tens of thousands of dollars on this railroad with 2,500 feet of track that go around the property. And he has a 90-foot tunnel that will take the train underneath his wife's flower garden. His wife isn't tremendously keen on this new... Yeah, she'd rather have the dungeon, frankly. Then he decides, well, I'd like, you know, why stop there? Why stop with trains?
他说，不，不，不。我必须为我的铁路留出空间。他在这条铁路上花费了数万美元，有 2500 英尺的轨道环绕着房产。他有一个 90 英尺长的隧道，可以让火车从他妻子的花园下面穿过。他妻子对这个新……不太热衷。是的，坦率地说，她宁愿要那个地牢。然后他决定，好吧，我想，你知道，为什么要停在那里？为什么要停在火车上？
He becomes really interested in the idea of artificial worlds. And he goes to miniature shops when he goes to Europe on holiday, to buy little miniature fixtures for his little train set. And he starts obsessively collecting furniture and kind of even little kind of liquor bottles and groceries and stuff like this. But the thing that's fascinating about that is that it's such a feature of his great animations as well, the obsessive interest in bottles and pots and pans and things. I mean, he obviously loved all that.
他对人造世界的想法变得非常感兴趣。当他去欧洲度假时，他会去微型商店，为他的小火车模型购买小微型固定装置。他开始痴迷地收集家具，甚至还有小酒瓶和杂货之类的东西。但关于这一点令人着迷的是，这也是他伟大动画的一个特征，对瓶子、锅碗瓢盆和东西的痴迷兴趣。我的意思是，他显然喜欢所有这些。
Yeah. He's just a massive, massive collector, I think. And he wasn't Walt Disney. He'd be the kind of person who absolutely had a shed with a giant train set or a model, you know, a model village or something. And as always with Disney, his enthusiasm, you talked about last time about him being a perfectionist, his enthusiasm runs completely out of control. So by 1950, he's basically working on this model American small town. If you remember Marcelline, the place where he had grown up in Missouri, he basically
是的。他只是一个巨大的、巨大的收藏家，我想。他不是华特·迪士尼。他会是那种绝对有一个带巨大火车模型或模型村庄之类的棚屋的人。而且正如迪士尼一贯的那样，他的热情，你上次谈到他是一个完美主义者，他的热情完全失控了。所以到 1950 年，他基本上在研究这个美国小镇模型。如果你还记得马塞林（Marcelline），他小时候在密苏里州长大的地方，他基本上
must to create this kind of Lilliputian Marcelline. And he has an idea that he could create a traveling exhibition called Disneylandia. And Disneylandia would be this kind of idealized miniature version of an American small town and it would have painted backdrops in the style of the... hugely popular mid-century artist Norman Rockwell. Now, Rockwell was by far the most popular painter with the masses in America in the 1940s, 1950s, 1960s and so on. More than Jackson Pollock. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So critics said, oh, Rockwell is so sentimental and so kitch and corny and whatnot. But ordinary people loved him. And that, of course, is an interesting parallel
必须创造这种小人国的马塞林。他有一个想法，他可以创建一个名为“迪士尼乐园”（Disneylandia）的巡回展览。而“迪士尼乐园”将是这种美国小镇的理想化微型版本，它将有世纪中期非常受欢迎的艺术家诺曼·洛克威尔（Norman Rockwell）风格的手绘背景。现在，洛克威尔是 20 世纪 40 年代、50 年代、60 年代等美国大众中最受欢迎的画家。比杰克逊·波洛克（Jackson Pollock）还受欢迎。哦，是的。是的。是的。所以评论家说，哦，洛克威尔太感伤了，太媚俗了，太老套了等等。但普通人喜欢他。当然，这是一个有趣的平行线
with Disney and indeed with Disneyland. Anyway, people in the film industry, when they came to see Disney in the late 40s and early 50s, they thought he'd gone completely bonkers. They would turn up expecting to talk about films. And he'd just be messing around with miniature bottles, bottle trains and stuff. So there's the great critic of the New York Times,
与迪士尼，实际上与迪士尼乐园。总之，电影业的人在 40 年代末和 50 年代初来看迪士尼时，他们认为他完全疯了。他们会来期待谈论电影。而他只会摆弄微型瓶子、瓶子火车之类的东西。所以有《纽约时报》的伟大评论家，
Bosley Crowther. Of course, he's called Bosley Crowther. He arrives and he says, I felt really sad when I saw what had become of Walt Disney that all of his zest for invention for creating fantasies was going into these sort of silly little playthings and toys and whatnot. Do you know, I don't think that Bosley Crowther can have been that great a critic if he couldn't have seen the parallels between the train set and the films.
博斯利·克劳瑟（Bosley Crowther）。当然，他叫博斯利·克劳瑟。他到了，他说，当我看到华特·迪士尼变成了什么样子时，我感到非常难过，他所有的发明热情、创造幻想的热情都投入到了这些愚蠢的小玩意和玩具之类的东西里。你知道，我不认为博斯利·克劳瑟能成为那么伟大的评论家，如果他看不出火车模型和电影之间的平行之处的话。
Yeah, well, I think you're right. And actually, the fact that it's trains, I think, is really revealing and interesting. And I think it's a clue to Disneyland's appeal. Trains in the 1940s and 1950s have a kind of a... slightly unusual image. People still see them as emblematic of speed and excitement and modernity, but of course, they're already being overtaken by air travel and by the car. Yeah. So they are simultaneously exciting. Who doesn't like riding on a train and pulling the whistle and seeing their landscape whistling past. But at the same time, they're slightly backward looking.
是的，好吧，我想你是对的。而且事实上，它是火车，我认为这真的很能说明问题，很有趣。我认为这是迪士尼乐园吸引力的线索。20 世纪 40 年代和 50 年代的火车有一种……稍微不寻常的形象。人们仍然认为它们是速度、兴奋和现代性的象征，但当然，它们已经被航空旅行和汽车所取代。是的。所以它们同时令人兴奋。谁不喜欢坐火车、拉汽笛、看着风景呼啸而过呢？但与此同时，它们又有点向后看。
Well, they're kind of iconic, aren't they, of Buffalo? Yeah, late 19th century. The railroad. All of that, Exactly. Casey Jones. And I think you mentioned before, Neil Gabler's definitive really life of Walt Disney. He sees the theme of Disney's life as a craving for kind of total control. And by creating a little train set or a model train or an artificial world, he's creating his own private world, a world that is exciting but is also nostalgic and is a refuge from the pressures of the present. And also, of course, the same thing about trains is they have to stay on the tracks that have been laid down by the person who's built them. Yeah.
嗯，它们是某种标志性的，不是吗，布法罗？是的，19 世纪末。铁路。所有这些，没错。凯西·琼斯（Casey Jones）。我想你之前提到了尼尔·盖布勒那本权威的华特·迪士尼传记。他认为迪士尼一生的主题是对某种绝对控制的渴望。通过创造一个小火车模型或模型火车或人造世界，他正在创造他自己的私人世界，一个令人兴奋但也是怀旧的世界，是逃避现实压力的避难所。而且，当然，关于火车的同样的事情是它们必须保持在由建造它们的人铺设的轨道上。是的。
They can't just go off peace. There's no unrulyness to a train set, right? A train set is perfectly ordered and harmonious. And you can see why this actually would have a wider appeal in the 1940s and 1950s. So the Second World War, with all its horrors, is only just over. By the early 1950s, the Korean War is raging at a cost of at least 36,000 American lives. A war actually is largely forgotten today, but very close. traumatic at the time. There's huge anxiety about communism and the Cold War and the shadow of the
它们不能只是偏离轨道。火车模型没有不守规矩，对吧？火车模型是完美有序和和谐的。你可以看出为什么这在 20 世纪 40 年代和 50 年代会有更广泛的吸引力。所以第二次世界大战，带着所有的恐怖，才刚刚结束。到 20 世纪 50 年代初，朝鲜战争正在肆虐，造成至少 36000 名美国人丧生。一场今天在很大程度上被遗忘的战争，但在当时非常接近。创伤性的。人们对共产主义、冷战和炸弹的阴影有巨大的焦虑。
bomb. So this is the heyday of McCarthyism of the kind of hunt for traitors and enemies within and so on and so forth. Which Disney is a part of. Which Disney is a part of, exactly. And at the same time, America itself, the sort of urban and geographical fabric of America is changing so rapidly. You know, this is the age of suburbanization of interstate highways, lots of new technology, big new corporations, lots of talk at the time about the new age of the kind of mass man and mass bureaucracy. And the individual, the small scale, the backward looking and the traditional, all these things are being crushed by this sort of new age of the kind of madmen, IBM, big corporations. And also, I suppose, cars. Yeah, of course. And I guess one of the interesting
所以这是麦卡锡主义的全盛时期，某种对叛徒和内部敌人的搜捕等等。迪士尼也是其中的一部分。迪士尼也是其中的一部分，没错。与此同时，美国本身，美国的城市和地理结构正在迅速改变。你知道，这是郊区化、州际公路、大量新技术、大型新公司的时代，当时有很多关于大众人和大众官僚机构新时代的讨论。个人、小规模、向后看和传统，所有这些东西都被这种疯狂的人、IBM、大公司的这种新时代所粉碎。而且，我想，还有汽车。是的，当然。而且我猜其中一个有趣的
things about Disneyland is that it is one of the few places where you can't take a car and you actually You have to walk. Exactly. Yeah. A lot of people there surely have never walked before. They all looked exhausted. So how do we get from there to the amusement park? Well, Disney's friends and family all had their own theories about where the idea for an amusement
关于迪士尼乐园的事情是，它是少数几个你不能开车进去的地方之一，你实际上必须步行。没错。是的。那里很多人肯定以前从来没有走过路。他们看起来都精疲力竭。那么我们是如何从那里走到游乐园的呢？好吧，迪士尼的朋友和家人都有他们自己关于游乐园想法来自哪里的理论。
park came from. So his daughter Diane said he used to take me to Griffith Park in L.A. to the Merrigo round at the weekend. His brother Roy said, oh, I'm sure that all this came from the trains. I think that's probably wrong. I think the trains were always, you know, I think the park was always in his imagination and the trains are always a step towards that. Well, I mean, it's in Pinocchio.
所以他的女儿黛安说，他过去常在周末带我去洛杉矶的格里菲斯公园坐旋转木马。他的兄弟罗伊说，哦，我敢肯定这一切都来自火车。我认为这可能是错的。我认为火车总是，你知道，我认为公园总是在他的想象中，而火车总是迈向那一步。嗯，我的意思是，它在《木偶奇遇记》里。
I mean, that's what's so interesting, you know, the Fantasy Island park. Yeah, of course, the Pleasure Island. Which is a nightmarish vision of a park. It's kind of interesting. That's the first manifestation of a park as far as I'm aware in, you know, Disney's sinking, and it's a nightmare. Walt had always enjoyed parks. So a friend of his from Kansas City said they had been to a park called Electric Park
我的意思是，这就是为什么它如此有趣，你知道，梦幻岛公园。是的，当然，快乐岛。这是一个噩梦般的公园愿景。这很有趣。据我所知，这是公园在迪士尼思想中的第一次体现，而且它是一个噩梦。华特一直很喜欢公园。所以他的一位来自堪萨斯城的朋友说，他们在 1910 年代去过堪萨斯城一个叫“电力公园”（Electric Park）的公园。现在，电力公园，我查了一下，曾经有
in Kansas City in the 1910s. Now, Electric Park, I looked this up, used to get a, million visitors a year. God, that's a lot, isn't it? It was nicknamed Kansas City's Coney Island. And he said, I remember going to Electric Park with Walt and Walt saying, gosh, as basically a teenager, Walt saying, God, I'd love to build a park one day, wouldn't you? And Gabba's biography, he says, you know, there's loads of occasions in the 1930s and 1940s where he mentioned to his animators, wouldn't it be fun one day to have a little park? You know, maybe we could have something across the road from our studio in Burbank,
一年一百万游客。天哪，那很多，不是吗？它被称为“堪萨斯城的康尼岛”。他说，我记得和华特一起去电力公园，华特说，天哪，基本上作为一个青少年，华特说，天哪，我有一天想建一个公园，你不觉得吗？在盖布勒的传记中，他说，你知道，在 20 世纪 30 年代和 40 年代，他有很多次向他的动画师提到，有一天建一个小公园不是很有趣吗？你知道，也许我们可以在伯班克工作室的马路对面建点什么，
across Riverside Drive. We could have a train. We could have a model village. We could have a couple of rides. I mean, if people ever wanted to come and visit the studio, because Disney is becoming a household name, we'd have something to show them and something for them to have fun with. And actually, when he went to that Chicago Railroad Fair, he was talking about what that would look like. He was saying, well, you could have a hot dog stand and you could have a,
穿过河滨大道。我们可以有一列火车。我们可以有一个模型村庄。我们可以有几个游乐设施。我的意思是，如果人们曾经想来参观工作室，因为迪士尼正在成为家喻户晓的名字，我们会有些东西可以展示给他们，让他们玩得开心。事实上，当他去那个芝加哥铁路博览会时，他正在谈论那看起来会是什么样子。他说，好吧，你可以有一个热狗摊，你可以有一个
a river boat and you could have a merry go around and all this. By the time he comes back from this railroad fare, he's really excited. And he has a tremendous sense of mission, which I think it's the first time he's had that sense of a vision and idealism and an esprit decor since working on Snow White in the late 1930s. And in 1951, he assembles his team and he says, right, I want you to go out across the country and I want you to get ideas. for a park. How would this work? They go to the Lincoln Museum in Chicago. They go to all sorts of colonial museums in New England. They go to all kinds of railroad and steamboat museums. They even go to a place I've actually been to, which is the open air museum in Colonial Williamsburg,
河船，你可以有一个旋转木马，所有这些。当他从这个铁路博览会回来时，他真的很兴奋。他有一种巨大的使命感，我认为这是他自 20 世纪 30 年代末制作《白雪公主》以来第一次拥有那种愿景、理想主义和团队精神的感觉。1951 年，他召集了他的团队，他说，好吧，我要你们去全国各地，我要你们去获取公园的想法。这怎么行得通？他们去了芝加哥的林肯博物馆。他们去了新英格兰的各种殖民博物馆。他们去了各种铁路和汽船博物馆。他们甚至去了我实际上去过的一个地方，那就是殖民地威廉斯堡的露天博物馆，
where everybody pretends. Like a sort of... Yeah, people dress up in costume, don't they? And talking the old English. Exactly. They're talking what they consider old English. And they bang anvils in blacksmith's shops. Well, that's what they do. in the 17th century. Exactly. And actually, American history is always a massive element
每个人都在假装。像某种……是的，人们穿着戏服，不是吗？说着古英语。没错。他们说着他们认为的古英语。他们在铁匠铺里敲铁砧。嗯，这就是他们在 17 世纪所做的事情。没错。事实上，美国历史总是迪士尼乐园吸引力的一个巨大元素。
of Disneyland's appeal. I mean, actually, you know, even now, there's a kind of, there's the hall of the presidents and there's kind of an animatronic Lincoln
我的意思是，事实上，你知道，即使现在，有一种，有总统大厅，还有某种电子林肯
and all of this. And that's exactly how Walt always imagined it. But interestingly, he doesn't just send them to America. He sends them to Europe. Hooray. And in the autumn in 1951,
以及所有这些。这正是华特一直想象的样子。但有趣的是，他不仅把他们送到美国。他把他们送到欧洲。万岁。1951 年秋天，
he sends Roy Disney, his brother, to Europe. And he says, I'd like you to go to Europe and see how they're They do things there and investigate buying amusement rides from Europe. Now, some of our listeners may be quite surprised at that,
他派他的兄弟罗伊·迪士尼去欧洲。他说，我希望你去欧洲看看他们是怎么做事的，并调查从欧洲购买游乐设施。现在，我们的一些听众可能会对此感到非常惊讶，
because they will think of Disneyland as quintessentially American, and they probably will think of amusement parks as quintessentially American. But this is wrong, Tom. Is it? Yeah. Disneyland is effectively European, as I will now explain. So Euro Disney, really, it was the park coming home. I guess so, yeah.
因为他们会认为迪士尼乐园是典型的美国式，他们可能会认为游乐园是典型的美国式。但这是错的，汤姆。是吗？是的。迪士尼乐园实际上是欧洲的，正如我现在要解释的那样。所以欧洲迪士尼，真的，它是公园回家了。我想是的，是的。
Euro Disney, which initially wasn't very successful, because it turned out their biggest market, which was in Britain. People associated the word Euro, not with cosmopolitanism, excitement and sophistication, but with committees of people deliberating on the length of sausages. Or similar. The Maastricht Treaty ride. Exactly.
欧洲迪士尼，最初并不太成功，因为它证明了他们最大的市场，也就是在英国。人们将“欧洲”这个词联系在一起，不是与国际化、兴奋和精致联系在一起，而是与讨论香肠长度的委员会联系在一起。或者类似的东西。马斯特里赫特条约游乐设施。没错。
Thrills and spells. Jean-Claude. It was a Juncker experience. An animatronic. I don't know. What's his name? Herman Rumpuy, or whatever's name is. Well, now answer your questions about subsistence.
惊险与咒语。让-克洛德。这是一个容克体验。一个电子动画。我不知道。他叫什么名字？赫尔曼·范龙佩（Herman Van Rompuy），或者不管他叫什么名字。好吧，现在回答你关于生存的问题。
Cityarity. Brilliant. Love it. All right. So let's get into the prehistory. What's the oldest park in the world? The oldest park is in Copenhagen. And it's the world's longest operating amusement park. It is a place called Backen, which was originally just outside Copenhagen, kind of to the north, I think. And Backen had its first visitors in the 1580s. So what were they going on? Kind of merry-go-rounds, roller coasters. They were not going on rides at all. excited by the possibility of a spring. I don't know. In what way is going to look at the spring? How does that count as a theme park?
城市性。太棒了。喜欢它。好吧。那么让我们进入史前史。世界上最古老的公园是什么？最古老的公园在哥本哈根。它是世界上运营时间最长的游乐园。它是一个叫“巴肯”（Backen）的地方，最初就在哥本哈根郊外，我想是在北边。巴肯在 1580 年代有了第一批游客。那么他们去玩什么？某种旋转木马、过山车。他们根本没有去玩游乐设施。对泉水的可能性感到兴奋。我不知道。去看泉水怎么算作主题公园？
So they would go to the spring, right? People would go out and the spring for a day out. And everyone was very excited by this spring. They thought, brilliant. God, it's 15-80s and there's nothing else to do. So back in the area, kind of at various points, it's made a royal hunting ground, and then the royals, the Danish rules will say, oh, let's throw it open again. People love that spring.
所以他们会去泉水，对吧？人们会出去，泉水是一天的出游。每个人都对这个泉水感到非常兴奋。他们想，太棒了。天哪，是 1580 年代，没有别的事情可做。所以巴肯地区，在某种程度上，它被设为皇家狩猎场，然后皇室，丹麦统治者会说，哦，让我们再次开放它。人们喜欢那个泉水。
But in what way is that a... An amusement park. Because so many people are going to see this spring. It attracts. You get entertainers. You get musicians setting up shop there. You get people selling food. It becomes basically a place that you go on a weekend, for example,
但它在什么方面是一个……游乐园。因为有这么多人去看这个泉水。它吸引了。你有了艺人。你有了在那里开店的音乐家。你有了卖食物的人。它基本上变成了一个你周末去的地方，例如，
on a feast day or a fair day. You go for a day out from the city. You know, it's always there. And there's all kinds of attractions. So there might be some amusing Danish juggler. There might be a man selling a meat pie. There might be an animal. an amusing animal being tortured in some hideous manner.
在节日或集市日。你从城市出来玩一天。你知道，它总是在那里。而且有各种各样的景点。所以可能会有一些有趣的丹麦杂耍演员。可能会有一个卖肉馅饼的人。可能会有一只动物。一只有趣的动物以某种可怕的方式被折磨。
Those long Danish days, just flown by. Exactly. So it becomes, you know, an escapist tourist destination. But that's not the most famous amusement park, is it? No. In Copenhagen. So it's still going today, but in 1843, back in God, arrival. And this was a much more famous park, but much closer to Copenhagen,
那些漫长的丹麦日子，就这样飞逝而过。没错。所以它变成了一个逃避现实的旅游目的地。但那不是最著名的游乐园，是吗？不。在哥本哈根。所以它今天还在运营，但在 1843 年，巴肯天哪，到来。这是一个更著名的公园，但离哥本哈根更近，
though at the time, just outside the city walls. And it's a park I've been to, actually, many times. Yeah, I love it. The Tivoli Gardens. So Tivoli was developed by a former Danish army officer called Georg Cartonson. And it had lots of elements right from the beginning from the 1840s that are very familiar at Tivoli today and indeed at many amusement parks today. It had flower gardens. It had a restaurant.
尽管当时就在城墙外。而且这是一个我实际上去过很多次的公园。是的，我喜欢它。蒂沃利花园（Tivoli Gardens）。所以蒂沃利是由一位名叫乔治·卡滕森（Georg Cartonson）的前丹麦军官开发的。它从 1840 年代开始就有许多元素，这些元素在今天的蒂沃利以及今天的许多游乐园中都非常熟悉。它有花坛。它有餐厅。
It had cafes. It had a theatre. It had a bandstand. It had fireworks displays. And the general vibe, which will be, if you've been to Tivoli, you will recognise, it's slightly exotic and kind of orientalist. Because they're opening, Disney are opening a new park, aren't they, in the Gulf? Oh, they? Yeah.
它有咖啡馆。它有剧院。它有乐队看台。它有烟花表演。而且总体氛围，如果你去过蒂沃利，你会认出来的，它有点异国情调和某种东方主义。因为他们正在开放，迪士尼正在开放一个新公园，不是吗，在海湾？哦，他们吗？是的。
And I wonder whether there will be an orientalist vibe there. Maybe there'd be an Occidentalist vibe. That would be an interesting twist. It would be quite a fun, wouldn't it? Yeah. Timber-framed cottages or something. Yeah. Anyway, Tivoli from the beginning had rides.
我想知道那里是否会有东方主义氛围。也许会有西方主义氛围。那将是一个有趣的转折。那会很有趣，不是吗？是的。木框架小屋之类的。是的。总之，蒂沃利从一开始就有游乐设施。
So Tivoli had a merry-go round and it had a scenic railway. We'll come back to the rides and the history of rides in a second. But most writers who have discussed the history of Disneyland agree that Tivoli is the single biggest inspiration. It is by far the most obvious model. And Disney sent his staff there multiple times. And one of the things that makes it such an obvious model is that Tivoli from the beginning had a very strong fairy tale element to it. And that's down to Hans Christian Anderson. Hans Christian Anderson was a friend of Georg Cartonson. He visited Tivoli during its very first season and he was inspired by Tivoli's Chinese pavilion to write his fairy tale,
所以蒂沃利有一个旋转木马和一个观光铁路。我们稍后再回到游乐设施和游乐设施的历史。但大多数讨论迪士尼乐园历史的作家都同意蒂沃利是最大的灵感来源。它是迄今为止最明显的模型。迪士尼多次派他的员工去那里。使它成为如此明显模型的一件事是，蒂沃利从一开始就有一种非常强烈的童话元素。这要归功于汉斯·克里斯蒂安·安徒生。汉斯·克里斯蒂安·安徒生是乔治·卡滕森的朋友。他在蒂沃利的第一季期间参观了蒂沃利，他受到蒂沃利中国馆的启发，写了他的童话，
the Nightingale. And there's actually now Hans Christian Anderson rides actively, and you can't really miss his influence when you go. Well, I mean, this is all very interesting. We've had quite a lot of America. We've had quite a lot of Denmark. But I feel what is lacking so far in this episode, no offence, is Britain. Yeah, you're not wrong. Surely there's some British influence. Of course there is. Isn't there? Because we are a patriotic podcast, and I'm very pleased to tell the listeners that Disneyland is effectively British. It's a British creation. Because Disneyland is modelled on Tivoli, and Tivoli's original name was actually Tivoli and Vauxhall. Now, the Tivoli bit alludes to the Gendar de Tivoli in Paris, a public park, a garden.
《夜莺》。而且现在实际上有汉斯·克里斯蒂安·安徒生的游乐设施，当你去的时候，你真的不能错过他的影响。嗯，我的意思是，这一切都非常有趣。我们已经有了很多美国。我们已经有了很多丹麦。但我感觉到目前为止这期节目中缺少的是英国，没有冒犯的意思。是的，你没说错。肯定有一些英国影响。当然有。不是吗？因为我们是一个爱国播客，我很高兴告诉听众迪士尼乐园实际上是英国的。它是英国的创造。因为迪士尼乐园是以蒂沃利为模型的，而蒂沃利最初的名字实际上是“蒂沃利和沃克斯豪尔”。现在，蒂沃利部分暗示了巴黎的蒂沃利花园，一个公园，一个花园。
But Vauxhall is Britain, South London, the Vauxhall Pleasure Gardens, the most influential pleasure park, I would say, in human history. Well, it's great to have Vauxhall, which is the tube station that serves the Oval on the podcast. Great to get the Oval back on the rest of history. Right. That's the last time we'll be mentioning the Oval in this podcast. So Vauxhall. Vauxhall began as the new Spring Gardens on the South Bank of the Thames. The date that it opened is unclear, but it was almost certainly around the time of the restoration.
但沃克斯豪尔是英国，伦敦南区，沃克斯豪尔游乐园，我认为是人类历史上最有影响力的游乐园。嗯，很高兴有沃克斯豪尔，也就是服务于椭圆球场（The Oval）的地铁站出现在播客上。很高兴让椭圆球场回到《历史的余味》。好吧。这是我们最后一次在这个播客中提到椭圆球场。所以沃克斯豪尔。沃克斯豪尔始于泰晤士河南岸的新泉花园。它开业的日期不清楚，但几乎肯定是在复辟时期左右。
In 1662, Samuel Peepes describes a visit to what he calls. Fox Hall, where I had not been a great while. And he and his wife collect flowers, and he says, we had cakes and salt beef and ale, and so home again by water with much pleasure. So they've obviously been for an outing. In 1667, five years later, the great sort of biographer and antiquarian John Aubrey records that the restoration era spy and double agent and inventor Samuel Morland built a house in the Vauxhall Pleasure Gardens, made of looking glass and fountains very pleasant to behold.
1662 年，塞缪尔·佩皮斯（Samuel Peepes）描述了一次访问他所谓的“福克斯豪尔”（Fox Hall），我有一段时间没去那里了。他和他的妻子收集花朵，他说，我们吃了蛋糕、咸牛肉和麦芽酒，然后带着很多快乐乘水路回家。所以他们显然是去郊游了。1667 年，五年后，伟大的传记作家和古物研究者约翰·奥布里（John Aubrey）记录说，复辟时代的间谍、双重间谍和发明家塞缪尔·莫兰（Samuel Morland）在沃克斯豪尔游乐园建造了一所房子，由镜子和喷泉制成，非常令人赏心悦目。
And there are all these sort of little trace descriptions of something going on in Vauxhall and the south bank of the Thames in the late 17th century. That's fun. That's basically, that's the point. Yeah, that it's fun. And people are going there for a day out. And it's hard to pin down exactly what they're going for because there aren't really detailed descriptions until the 18th century. And by the 18th century, we do have a very clear sense of this is one of London's great tourist attractions.
在17世纪末的沃克斯豪尔和泰晤士河南岸，有一些关于当时活动的零星描述。这很有趣。这基本上就是重点。是的，就是因为有趣。人们去那里度过一天。很难准确定义他们去那里的目的，因为直到18世纪才有详细的描述。到了18世纪，我们非常清楚地意识到，这是伦敦最伟大的旅游景点之一。
So now it has a proper sort of Walt Disney style entrepreneur in charge of it called Jonathan Tyers. And the reason I compare him with Walt Disney is that like Disney, Tyers is a kind of mid-market populist. So he's interested in throwing it open to as many people as possible, but with caveats. So he charges a shilling to get in. It doesn't sound like much, but I looked it up, the academic website measuring worth, in relative income terms, a shilling is the equivalent of about 150 pounds today, a lot of money, but almost exactly the same as what you would pay for a one-day ticket to Disneyland in Anaheim right
现在，它由一位真正的华特·迪士尼式的企业家负责，名叫乔纳森·泰尔斯。我把他与华特·迪士尼相提并论的原因是，像迪士尼一样，泰尔斯是一位中产阶级民粹主义者。所以他有兴趣向尽可能多的人开放，但也有附加条件。他收取一先令的入场费。这听起来不多，但我查了一下学术网站“衡量价值”，按相对收入计算，一先令相当于今天大约150英镑，这是一笔不小的钱，但几乎和你现在买一张阿纳海姆迪士尼乐园一日票的价格完全一样。
now. So it's keeping riff-raff out. You know, it's a proper event. You know, you don't go lightly. You go because it's a long you know, conceived trip, very exciting moment. And it will appeal to respectable people because the price of a shilling means you can be pretty confident there will not be the likes of the young Emma Hamilton. Correct. There will not be thieves and footpads and ruffians.
所以它把无赖挡在了外面。你知道，这是一个正式的活动。你知道，你不会轻易去。你去是因为这是一次经过深思熟虑的旅行，非常令人兴奋的时刻。它会吸引体面的人，因为一先令的价格意味着你可以相当肯定不会有像年轻的艾玛·汉密尔顿那样的人。没错。不会有小偷、扒手和流氓。
Yeah, and people of easy virtue. So what is it that they've got there? They've got musicians. They've got entertainers. There's lots of fireworks. There are Chinese lanterns. The Chinese lanterns are a huge part of this, actually. People would often comment on the excitement
是的，还有那些品行不端的人。那么他们那里有什么呢？他们有音乐家。他们有艺人。有很多烟花。还有中国灯笼。事实上，中国灯笼是其中的重要组成部分。人们经常评论那种兴奋感
of walking down the kind of the darkened paths illuminated at every turn by these lanterns. This then inspires a theme park in Russia, in St. Petersburg, and there's a railway station next to it called Vauxhall. And so the Russian word for railway station is Vauxhall. Vauxhall, yeah, exactly. Amazing. So they have more and more attractions. By the early 19th century, there are organs, there are multiple orchestras, there's a theatre,
走在黑暗的小路上，每一个转弯处都被这些灯笼照亮。这后来启发了俄罗斯圣彼得堡的一个主题公园，旁边有一个火车站叫沃克斯豪尔。所以俄语中火车站的词就是沃克斯豪尔。沃克斯豪尔，是的，完全正确。太神奇了。所以他们有越来越多的景点。到了19世纪初，有管风琴，有多个管弦乐队，有一个剧院，
there are hot air balloons, you would go in. you would see high wire acts, jugglers, there'd be puppet shows. The price has now gone up to three shillings, so it's pretty expensive. I think it's where the first giraffe is displayed in England. Is that right? I think so. You love a giraffe. You love a giraffe. Yeah, I do. Great to get a giraffe back on the show. Dickens went. It features briefly in Thackeray's novel Vanity Fair and so on and so forth. However, the temptation is always to go down market and that's exactly what happens. So chasing profits in the middle of the 19th century, Vauxhall's new proprietors, they basically lost some of the respectability. It got a reputation for bawdy behavior,
有热气球，你会进去。你会看到高空钢丝表演、杂耍，还有木偶戏。价格现在涨到了三先令，所以相当贵。我想这是英国第一个展示长颈鹿的地方。是这样吗？我想是的。你喜欢长颈鹿。你喜欢长颈鹿。是的，我喜欢。很高兴长颈鹿能回到节目中。狄更斯去过。它在萨克雷的小说《名利场》中简短地出现过，等等。然而，诱惑总是走向低端市场，而这正是所发生的事情。为了追求利润，在19世纪中期，沃克斯豪尔的新业主基本上失去了一些体面。它因淫秽行为、
for drinking, for late-night parties. And it ended up basically being threatened with losing its licenses, and it closed in 1859. Well, now, I mean, you mentioned sex dungeons. There was a, there's a club there, I think, called dungeon or something like that. Right. But that's nice to know. So, you see, every time you drive, you know, across from North London, going down to Brixton, it always used to be there. Right. Well, have you ever been? No, I haven't, but I always kind of wondered.
酗酒、深夜派对而声名狼藉。最终，它基本上受到了吊销执照的威胁，并于1859年关闭。好吧，现在，我的意思是，你提到了性地牢。那里有一个俱乐部，我想叫地牢之类的。没错。但这很高兴知道。所以，你看，每次你开车，你知道，从北伦敦穿过，去布里克斯顿，它总是以前在那里。没错。好吧，你去过吗？不，我没有，但我总是有点好奇。
Right. Well, that's a lovely, possible destination for a rest of history Christmas outing. Maybe for the Aphistans. So, yeah, exactly. So there's one thing, obviously, that Vauxhall is missing that actually back and didn't have either, as you pointed out, which is rides. Now, the thing is, I'm guessing most, I'm guessing everybody, you listen to this podcast. has been on a ride at some point in their life, if only is a very small child.
没错。好吧，那是一个可爱的、可能的历史休息圣诞郊游目的地。也许是为了Aphistans。所以，是的，完全正确。所以有一件事，显然，沃克斯豪尔缺少了，正如你指出的那样，巴克也没有，那就是游乐设施。现在，问题是，我猜大多数，我猜每个人，你听这个播客。在他们生命中的某个时刻都坐过游乐设施，即使只是作为一个非常小的孩子。
I think if my father is listening, he's never been on a ride, but apart from him. Surely he's been on a roundabout or some sort of... I can't imagine it. Well, but I'm also guessing that almost nobody has ever thought, gosh, rides have a history. Where do rides come from? No. Because you just take them for granted and you think of them as frivolous. So let's start with the first ride that most people ever take, the first sort of sophisticated ride.
我想如果我父亲在听，他从来没有坐过游乐设施，但除了他之外。他肯定坐过旋转木马或某种……我无法想象。好吧，但我也猜几乎没有人想过，天哪，游乐设施是有历史的。游乐设施是从哪里来的？不。因为你只是认为它们是理所当然的，并认为它们是轻浮的。所以让我们从大多数人坐的第一个游乐设施，第一种复杂的游乐设施开始。
And that's normally, I would say, probably a merry-go-round or a carousel. You know, the horse is going up and down. So the word carousel, a French word, and it originally meant this sort of test of skill during a tournament. So the claim is that you read everywhere is that this began, this was imported from the Saracens during the Crusades. They would ride on their horses, and they would basically spear with a lance, a ring that was hanging from a post. a tree. It's a kind of standard element of tournament activity in a children's history book. And in early modern Europe, this activity evolved into a much more formalized kind of display. So it's a little bit like dressage or something. So we know that, for example,
通常我会说，可能是旋转木马。你知道，马上下起伏。所以“carousel”这个词，一个法语词，最初是指锦标赛期间的一种技能测试。所以到处都能读到的说法是，这起源于十字军东征期间从撒拉逊人那里引进的。他们会骑在马上，基本上用长矛刺穿挂在柱子或树上的圆环。这是儿童历史书中锦标赛活动的标准元素。在近代早期的欧洲，这种活动演变成了一种更加正式的展示。所以它有点像盛装舞步之类的。所以我们知道，例如，
in 1662, in the summer of 1662, Louis XIV, held a big kind of carousel occasion in the courtyard of the Twillery Palace. And people were kind of riding up and down, and they were trying to collect these rings with their lances. And to this day, that square is called, which is now by the Louvre, is called the Place Du Carcocel. The game spread, well, the sort of the exhibition spread in popularity. By the 18th century, people are doing it in fares all over Europe. And people have developed, basically, I suspect because it's cheaper, a sort of very
在1662年，1662年的夏天，路易十四在杜乐丽宫的庭院里举办了一场大型的旋转木马活动。人们骑着马走来走去，试图用长矛收集这些圆环。直到今天，那个广场，现在在卢浮宫旁边，被称为卡鲁塞尔广场。这个游戏传播开来，嗯，这种展览的受欢迎程度传播开来。到了18世纪，人们在欧洲各地的集市上都在做这件事。人们基本上开发了，我怀疑是因为它更便宜，一种非常
primitive mechanical dimension. So you will sit on a kind of a wooden horse. Their wooden horses are suspended in a circle from a kind of axis and a central pole, rather like on a modern carousel. But they are rotated, obviously not by electricity or whatever. They're rotated by animals or basically by people just pulling on a rope. So there's some poor bloke sweating profusely pulling you while you're going round and round. It suddenly struck me. In John Wesley's house in London, he rode around everywhere preaching and all that stuff.
原始的机械维度。所以你会坐在一种木马上。它们的木马悬挂在一个圆圈里，从一种轴和中心杆上，很像现代的旋转木马。但它们被旋转，显然不是靠电力什么的。它们被动物旋转，或者基本上被人们拉着绳子旋转。所以有一个可怜的家伙汗流浃背地拉着你，而你却在转来转去。我突然想到。在伦敦的约翰·卫斯理家中，他到处骑马传教等等。
and that he had a mechanical horse. It was kind of the equivalent of an exercise bike. So he'd sit in it in the morning. It would go up and down, up and down. Yeah. And it would exercise his thighs and give him the strength to continue riding. So that is also part of the carousel, isn't it? That the horses go up and down.
他有一匹机械马。它有点像健身车。所以他早上会坐在上面。它会上下起伏，上下起伏。是的。它会锻炼他的大腿，给他继续骑马的力量。所以这也是旋转木马的一部分，不是吗？马上下起伏。
So presumably that's where that is coming from. Yeah. So that idea of, I mean, that's such an 18th century thing, isn't it? The idea of, you know, some mechanical contraption that you'll exercise on. Yeah. And some mad inventor has developed that basically, and you don't think of that being the ancestor of, you know, the roller coaster, Alton Towers or something, but that's exactly what it is. No, it hadn't crossed my mind when I saw it, but now you have enlightened me. Oh, that's wonderful.
所以大概这就是它的来源。是的。所以那个想法，我的意思是，那真是18世纪的事情，不是吗？你知道，某种你可以锻炼的机械装置的想法。是的。而某个疯狂的发明家基本上开发了它，你不会认为那是过山车、奥尔顿塔之类的祖先，但这正是它。不，当我看到它时，我没有想到，但现在你启发了我。哦，那太棒了。
For which many thanks. So the first proper mechanical carousel comes from the Napoleonic Wars. And this was a creation quite literally of Merlin of a man called Jean-Josef Merlin, who was an inventor who had moved from Lijge to London in the 1760s. and he was a big name at the time. I mean, he's completely forgotten today, but he was a very big name in the late 18th century. He was nicknamed the ingenious mechanic. And he made clocks, he made automata,
非常感谢。所以第一个真正的机械旋转木马来自拿破仑战争。这实际上是梅林，一个名叫让-约瑟夫·梅林的男人的创造，他是一位发明家，在1760年代从列日搬到了伦敦。他在当时是个大人物。我的意思是，他今天完全被遗忘了，但在18世纪末他是个非常大的人物。他被称为“天才机械师”。他制造钟表，制造自动机，
kind of robotic machines of various kinds. He made organs and pianos. He invented a self-repelled wheelchair. He invented a pedal-operated revolving tea table. And this is an amazing fact. he invented rollerblades so he was the first person to invent the line of wheels the thin line of wheels on a shoe or boot and he opened on a mechanical museum in hanover square which in the 1780s and 1790s was a very fashionable place to go for coffee and we know from traveller's accounts there's one from i think 1804 looking back at a journey he made a german traveler in 1803 and this bloke said i went to this place i couldn't believe it i went in there was a carousel it was completely mechanical, you'd go in that with a coffee and you'd sit on this horse and it would kind of go round and round, while an organ played a concerto.
各种各样的机器人机器。他制造管风琴和钢琴。他发明了一种自走式轮椅。他发明了一种踏板操作的旋转茶几。这是一个惊人的事实。他发明了旱冰鞋，所以他是第一个发明鞋子或靴子上细排轮子的人，他在汉诺威广场开了一家机械博物馆，在1780年代和1790年代，那里是一个非常时尚的喝咖啡的地方。我们从旅行者的叙述中知道，我想有一份来自1804年的，回顾他1803年的一次旅行，一个德国旅行者，这个家伙说我去了这个地方，我简直不敢相信，我进去后有一个旋转木马，它是完全机械的，你会带着咖啡进去，坐在那匹马上，它会转来转去，同时管风琴演奏协奏曲。
So, yeah, that basically is the experience they're going on a merry-go round. However, it was just a private toy. It was only for people who went to Merlin's museum. The man who made carousels for the masses was a Lancastrian, like our co-founder of Goulanger, a Tony Paster. So another great populist. This was a bloke called Thomas Bradshaw, who was an inventor from Bolton,
所以，是的，这基本上就是他们坐旋转木马的体验。然而，这只是一个私人玩具。它只供去梅林博物馆的人使用。为大众制造旋转木马的人是一个兰开夏人，就像我们的古朗格联合创始人托尼·帕斯特一样。所以又一位伟大的民粹主义者。这是一个叫托马斯·布拉德肖的家伙，他是博尔顿的一位发明家，
and he built a carousel with a steam engine, which is a big innovation. And he probably unveiled it in Bolton on New Year's Day, 1861. And then we have the first full account two years later. He took it to Halifax. And the local paper described it as,
他建造了一个带有蒸汽机的旋转木马，这是一个巨大的创新。他可能在1861年元旦在博尔顿揭幕了它。然后我们在两年后有了第一个完整的记录。他把它带到了哈利法克斯。当地报纸将其描述为，
and I quote, I was going to do the accent. Maybe I will do the accent. Hey, hey, hey, it's a rounder out of huge proportions driven by a steam engine which whirled around with such impetuosity that the wonder is the daring riders are not shut off like cannonballs
我引用一下，我本来想模仿口音。也许我会模仿口音。嘿，嘿，嘿，这是一个巨大的旋转木马，由蒸汽机驱动，以如此猛烈的速度旋转，令人惊奇的是，大胆的骑手没有像炮弹一样被甩出去，
and driven half into the middle of next month. They're not drinking coffee by this point. No, definitely not. So, that's Bradshaw with this steam-powered carousel. Now, he's actually just preparing the way for an even greater man. And this is the Walt Disney of Kings Lynn. Fred Savage, are you familiar with?
并被驱赶到下个月的一半。他们此时没有喝咖啡。不，绝对没有。所以，这就是布拉德肖和这个蒸汽动力的旋转木马。现在，他实际上只是为一位更伟大的人铺平道路。这就是金斯林的华特·迪士尼。弗雷德·萨维奇，你熟悉吗？
with Fred Savage's life and career, Tom? I think he clearly invents Disneyland, doesn't he? It should really be called Savage Land. It should. So he was born into a family of Weavers in 1828. He never really learned to read and write. His father was transported to Tasmania for poaching. And he began work as a farm labourer when he was 10.
弗雷德·萨维奇的生活和事业，汤姆？我想他显然发明了迪士尼乐园，不是吗？它真的应该叫萨维奇乐园。它应该。所以他出生于1828年的一个织布工家庭。他从未真正学会读写。他的父亲因偷猎被流放到塔斯马尼亚。他10岁时开始做农场工人。
But after his father disappeared, he needed more money. So he was apprenticed to a local machine maker. And he proved to be very good at making machines. He sets up his own business, making farm machinery, and then he diversifies into steam-powered fairground machinery. And Fred Savage becomes, by the 1880s, he is, without doubt, the most innovative and influential maker of rides in the world. So if I give you just three examples of his great rides, there was a roundabout called
但在他父亲失踪后，他需要更多的钱。所以他被送去给当地的一位机器制造商当学徒。事实证明他非常擅长制造机器。他创办了自己的企业，制造农用机械，然后多元化经营蒸汽动力的游乐场机械。到1880年代，弗雷德·萨维奇无疑是世界上最具创新性和影响力的游乐设施制造商。所以如果我只给你三个他伟大游乐设施的例子，有一个旋转木马叫
Sea on Land, where you'd sit in like a boat and it would pitch and toss as though you're on the waves. I mean, this is basically like you see at most fairgrounds, right? They have this ride. There was a steam-driven carousel, which was kind of the definitive carousel. It was called the Platform Gallupers. He had the idea of having you go up and down on coloured poles, you know, the bright colours and stuff, and the organ playing.
“陆上之海”，你会坐在像船一样的东西里，它会像你在波浪上一样俯仰和颠簸。我的意思是，这基本上就像你在大多数游乐场看到的那样，对吧？他们有这个游乐设施。有一个蒸汽驱动的旋转木马，它是某种决定性的旋转木马。它被称为“平台加洛普”。他想出了让你在彩色杆子上上下起伏的主意，你知道，鲜艳的颜色之类的，还有管风琴演奏。
And this then was copied all over the world, the Platform Gallopers. And then the most influential ride, so we at Disneyland have been on a ride very like this. It was called Switchbacks. and it was in 1888 and this had you sat in a kind of gilded car and a carriage and the carers raced around an undulating track. So the car's ride at Disneyland
这后来被全世界复制，即“平台加洛普”。然后是最具影响力的游乐设施，所以我们在迪士尼乐园坐过非常像这样的游乐设施。它被称为“Switchbacks”，是在1888年，这让你坐在一种镀金的车厢里，车厢在起伏的轨道上竞速。所以迪士尼乐园的车厢游乐设施
is basically just an updated version of the switchbacks ride. Amazing. And he was a huge figure in Kings Lynn. He became the mayor of Kings Lynn. There is a statue of him in Kingsland to this day. So that's very exciting. No one would pull that down.
基本上只是“Switchbacks”游乐设施的更新版本。太神奇了。他在金斯林是一个大人物。他成为了金斯林的市长。直到今天，金斯林还有他的雕像。所以这非常令人兴奋。没有人会把它拉下来。
No. He sounds great. Do you know who actually, love him is my cousin Simon, who he makes Victorian fairground attractions and paints them. He's a magnificent artist and kind of tinkerer. Well, that's exciting. Maybe he already knows about Fred Savage. I'd like to think he does. Probably does. I'll ask him. But there's one thing that Fred Savage can't take credit for. And in fact, I'm sorry to say that we in Britain can't take any credit for at all. And that's the roller coaster. So the roller coaster has a
不。他听起来很棒。你知道谁实际上，爱他的是我的表弟西蒙，他制作维多利亚时代的游乐场景点并为它们上色。他是一位伟大的艺术家和某种修补匠。好吧，那很令人兴奋。也许他已经知道弗雷德·萨维奇了。我想他知道。可能知道。我会问他。但有一件事弗雷德·萨维奇不能居功。事实上，我很遗憾地说，我们英国人根本不能居功。那就是过山车。所以过山车有一个
mad history, a very unexpected history. Roller coasters originated in 18th century, Tsarist, Russia. So basically, how it worked was in palaces outside St. Petersburg, in the age of Catherine the Great, serfs and servants would build these kind of undulating hills of ice so that their masters and mistresses could go to boggaining. Because it's all very flat, isn't it? It is flat, so that's why they'd build these mountains. And the mountains were called Catalaya Gorka, sliding mountains.
疯狂的历史，一个非常意想不到的历史。过山车起源于18世纪沙皇俄国。所以基本上，它是这样工作的：在圣彼得堡郊外的宫殿里，在叶卡捷琳娜大帝时代，农奴和仆人会建造这种冰制起伏的山丘，以便他们的主人和女主人可以去滑雪橇。因为那里非常平坦，不是吗？它是平坦的，所以这就是他们建造这些山的原因。这些山被称为“Catalaya Gorka”，即滑动山。
and they'd sometimes be 80 feet high and they would be sort of buttressed with wooden supports and over time the Russian abilities say well I enjoy this so much I'd like to do it in the summer when there's no ice so they build summer versions and they do them not with toboggins but with carts with wheels that roll down grooved tracks so the most famous one was a ride called the Riding Mountain it was built at Sarskoia Sello
它们有时有80英尺高，它们会用木支撑加固，随着时间的推移，俄罗斯贵族说，好吧，我非常喜欢这个，我想在夏天没有冰的时候做，所以他们建造了夏季版本，他们不是用雪橇，而是用带有轮子的车，在凹槽轨道上滚下来，所以最著名的是一个叫“骑行山”的游乐设施，它建在沙皇村，
the country retreat of the Tsars under Catherine the Great by Rastrelli the architect who did the Winter Palace. What's the health and safety? Listen, if Catherine the Great comes off that ride, you're in massive trouble. You cannot take any risk. I am not going to go on a ride
在叶卡捷琳娜大帝统治下，由建造冬宫的建筑师拉斯特雷利建造。健康和安全是什么？听着，如果叶卡捷琳娜大帝从那个游乐设施上掉下来，你就大难临头了。你不能冒任何风险。我不会去坐一个
that's been built in 18th century Russia. No way. What about 19th century Paris? So by the early 19th century, these have been copied in Paris. And the first one is called the Montagne-Rousse, Russian Mountains. And there's also one called Promenade Erieen. and they were both installed in an amusement park in 1817 off the Chonseilise.
建于18世纪俄罗斯的游乐设施。绝不。19世纪的巴黎呢？所以到了19世纪初，这些已经在巴黎被复制了。第一个被称为“Montagne-Rousse”，即俄罗斯山。还有一个叫“Promenade Erieen”。它们都在1817年安装在香榭丽舍大街附近的一个游乐园里。
And again, these have these wheeled cars running in grooves. You would tow your car to the top of a slope. You'd release it. It would whizz around the track. Louis, the 18th, came to see it. He came to see it, but he refused to ride in it. I'd very much doubt he could have fitted in it. Well, he's a very large man.
同样，这些有轮子的车在凹槽里运行。你会把你的车拖到斜坡顶上。你释放它。它会沿着轨道呼啸而过。路易十八来看过它。他来看过，但他拒绝坐它。我非常怀疑他是否能坐进去。好吧，他是一个非常大的人。
Yeah, he would have... The whole system would have crashed, splintered into timber beneath it. Unlike you at Disneyland, he thought it was beneath his dignity. But you did not. I piled in. Exactly. And what turns these things into a proper roller coaster is the addition of steam. And that, I have to say, is an American innovation.
是的，他会……整个系统会崩溃，在他身下碎成木头。不像你在迪士尼乐园，他认为这有损他的尊严。但你没有。我挤进去了。没错。而把这些东西变成真正的过山车的是蒸汽的加入。而且我必须说，这是一个美国的创新。
Oh, that's the shame. So this, I mean, the place, you couldn't make this up. I mean, American names is just absolutely insane. So the first railway that does this was called the Mork Chow. It was called the Mork Chunk Switchback Railway. It sounds like a pet food. And if you think that's bad, the town that it was, that it was building, was called, the town that it was built in, the town that it was built in was called Jim Thorpe. Who, who, who, who, who founded the town of Jim Thorpe, Dominic?
哦，那真是遗憾。所以这个，我的意思是，这个地方，你编不出这个。我的意思是，美国的名字简直太疯狂了。所以做这件事的第一条铁路叫“Mork Chunk”。它叫“Mork Chunk Switchback Railway”。它听起来像宠物食品。如果你认为这很糟糕，它建造的城镇，它建造的城镇，它建造的城镇叫吉姆·索普。谁，谁，谁，谁，谁建立了吉姆·索普镇，多米尼克？
Who could possibly say, very modest, very modest man. The town is called Jim Thorpe, Pennsylvania. And it's the Mork Chunk Switchback Railway. It was a sort of mining railway. but they called it the gravity road because it went so steeply downhill. And by 1870, the company that ran the Mork Chunk Railway decided that instead of using it for its proper purpose,
谁能说得准，非常谦虚，非常谦虚的人。这个镇叫宾夕法尼亚州吉姆·索普。它是“Mork Chunk Switchback Railway”。它是一种矿业铁路，但他们称它为重力路，因为它下坡非常陡峭。到1870年，经营Mork Chunk铁路的公司决定，与其将其用于其正当目的，
they would throw it open to tourists who were visiting Jim Thorpe. Where are you spending your vacation? Jim Thorpe. Not again. No, less a person, the Ulysses-S. Grant. Oh, the corrupt and boring president. Yeah, the corrupt and boring president
他们会向访问吉姆·索普的游客开放。你在哪里度假？吉姆·索普。不是又来了。不，少了一个人，尤利西斯·S·格兰特。哦，那个腐败而无聊的总统。是的，那个腐败而无聊的总统
of the United States, he traveled on it. So people hear the news of this Gravity Railway. They're like, brilliant, love it. And this bloke, another man who was called LaMarcus Adna Thompson. Where the hell did he come from? God knows. He built his own version called the Gravity Switchback Railway at Coney Island in the 1880s. And it was La Marcus Adna Thompson, who came up with the idea of you would travel against painted backdrops.
美国，他坐过它。所以人们听到这条重力铁路的消息。他们就像，太棒了，喜欢它。而这个家伙，另一个人叫拉马库斯·阿德纳·汤普森。他到底是从哪里来的？天知道。他在1880年代在康尼岛建造了自己的版本，叫“重力Switchback铁路”。正是拉马库斯·阿德纳·汤普森想出了在彩绘背景下旅行的主意。
So you basically pretend you're in the Swiss Alps or something. And from there, you soon get moved towards having loops, so in other words, going upside down. Again, Coney Island leads the way on that. So the amusingly named Flip Flap Railway, which opened in 1895, has a loop so that you go upside down. And then there are basically versions in amusement parks all over the world in the next 30 to 40 years, which is kind of the golden age of roller coasters.
所以你基本上假装你在瑞士阿尔卑斯山之类的。从那里，你很快就会转向有环路，换句话说，倒挂。同样，康尼岛在这方面处于领先地位。所以1895年开业的有趣命名的“Flip Flap铁路”有一个环路，这样你就可以倒挂。然后在接下来的30到40年里，世界各地的游乐园基本上都有版本，这算是过山车的黄金时代。
Actually, we think of it as now, but there are probably more roller coasters than the 1920s than there are right now. They all have one thing in common and they have that in common with Catherine the Great's riding mountain which you distrust. They are all made of wood.
事实上，我们现在认为它是，但1920年代的过山车可能比现在多。它们都有一个共同点，而且它们与你怀疑的叶卡捷琳娜大帝的骑行山有共同点。它们都是木制的。
So the very first steel roller coaster was not open until 1959. It is called the Matterhorn bobsleds. I believe Tabby has ridden on it because where does it open, Tom? It opens at Disneyland. Disneyland. You know, I'd completely forgotten about Disneyland.
所以第一个钢制过山车直到1959年才开放。它被称为“马特洪峰雪橇”。我相信塔比坐过它，因为它在哪里开放，汤姆？它在迪士尼乐园开放。迪士尼乐园。你知道，我完全忘记了迪士尼乐园。
Yeah. Well, finally got back on track, as it were. So let's have a quick break now. And when we come back, we will be in 1950s, California. And we'll be finding out what has happened to Walt Disney's theme park. To all who come to this happy place, welcome. Disneyland is your land. Here, age, relives, fond, memories of the past, and here youth may savor the challenge and promise of the future. Disneyland is dedicated to the ideals, the dreams, and the hard facts that have created America, with the hope that it will be a source of joy and inspiration to all the world. I don't know if that's how Walt Disney spoke, but in my version it is, because that was Walt Disney and he was unveiling his park to the world's press on the 17th of July, 1995. And Dominic, in those words, are lots of the themes that we would associate with Disneyland today.
是的。好吧，终于回到了正轨。所以现在让我们休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将身处1950年代的加利福尼亚。我们将找出华特·迪士尼的主题公园发生了什么。致所有来到这个快乐地方的人，欢迎。迪士尼乐园是你的乐园。在这里，年龄重温过去的美好回忆，在这里，年轻人可以品味未来的挑战和希望。迪士尼乐园致力于创造美国的理想、梦想和硬事实，希望它能成为全世界欢乐和灵感的源泉。我不知道华特·迪士尼是不是那样说话的，但在我的版本里是，因为那是华特·迪士尼，他在1955年7月17日向世界媒体揭幕他的公园。多米尼克，在这些话中，有很多我们今天会与迪士尼乐园联系在一起的主题。
So kind of looking backwards, lots of sepia-tinged nostalgia, but also the excitement of the future, and there's idealism, and there's this kind of patriotic sense that American history is something to be celebrated. Exactly, yeah. So we finally got back to Disneyland, and before we get to the opening day, let's backtrack a little to explain how we got to 1955. So we left the story with Walt sending his emissaries to Europe to get inspiration from Tivoli and indeed from Vauxhall, if only indirectly. And they have returned full of ideas, and they get down to work in the early 1950s.
所以有点回顾过去，很多怀旧情绪，但也对未来感到兴奋，有理想主义，还有一种爱国感，即美国历史是值得庆祝的。没错，是的。所以我们终于回到了迪士尼乐园，在开幕日之前，让我们回溯一下，解释我们是如何到达1955年的。所以我们离开故事时，华特派他的特使去欧洲从蒂沃利，甚至从沃克斯豪尔那里获得灵感，即使只是间接的。他们带着满满的想法回来了，并在1950年代初开始工作。
The plan is going to have to change, A, because it's much grander than before, Walt wants something huge, but also because the city authorities in Burbank say, look, we don't want a children's entertainment park via the studios. You're going to have to look somewhere else. So Walt commissions this study to find a new site. And they report to him in the summer of 1953, and they say, look, Greater Los Angeles, because of the huge suburbanization in Eisenhower's America, is expanding at a vast rate. And the highest rate of growth is expected to be, in suburban Orange County, which is just south of Los Angeles.
计划必须改变，A，因为它比以前宏大得多，华特想要巨大的东西，但也因为伯班克的城市当局说，看，我们不想要工作室提供的儿童娱乐公园。你必须去别处看看。所以华特委托这项研究寻找一个新地点。他们在1953年夏天向他报告，他们说，看，大洛杉矶，因为艾森豪威尔时代的美国巨大的郊区化，正在以巨大的速度扩张。而增长率最高的地方预计是在洛杉矶南部的郊区奥兰治县。
Now, there are a couple of interesting things about Orange County. One, it already has a theme park called Knott's Berry Farm, which lots of our American listeners will have heard of, which is basically a farm shop that's built its own ghost town, fake ghost town as an attraction. What do you mean a ghost town? A town with ghost, like Scooby-Doo, or... A sort of abandoned, like, western town.
现在，关于奥兰治县有几件有趣的事情。第一，它已经有一个叫“诺茨浆果农场”的主题公园，我们很多美国听众都听说过，它基本上是一个农场商店，建造了自己的鬼城，假的鬼城作为景点。你说的鬼城是什么意思？一个有鬼的城镇，像史酷比，或者……一种废弃的，像西部城镇。
Miners Town. Yeah, a saloon and stuff. but I think there was also a more spectral element to it. Yeah. I mean, now there's loads of rides and things. It's very popular. So with sinister janitors who turn out to be faking ghosts, that kind of thing. Exactly.
矿工镇。是的，沙龙之类的。但我认为它还有一个更幽灵的元素。是的。我的意思是，现在有很多游乐设施之类的。它非常受欢迎。所以有险恶的看门人，结果是假装鬼魂，那种事情。没错。
I mean, I have to say an absolutely preposterous name for a theme park, Nottsbury Farm. It's not that scary, is it? But very popular in America. The other thing about Orange County is a hugely symbolic place in post-war American politics. It's the birthplace of Richard Nixon, but it is the heartland of kind of Barry Goldwater, Ronald Reagan, conservatism. There's a whole book called Suburban Warriors by historical Lisa McGur, all about Orange County
我的意思是，我必须说，一个主题公园的名字简直荒谬，诺茨浆果农场。它没那么可怕，是吗？但在美国非常受欢迎。关于奥兰治县的另一件事是战后美国政治中一个极具象征意义的地方。它是理查德·尼克松的出生地，但它是巴里·戈德华特、罗纳德·里根保守主义的大本营。有一本整本书叫《郊区战士》，由历史学家丽莎·麦格尔所写，全是关于奥兰治县
as the sort of petri dish in which modern American conservatism was made. Anyway, it's here that Walt Disney decides he'll have his park. He buys 160 acres of orange groves in Anaheim, and he says, right, now we have to pay for it. Now, the budget for Disneyland ends up ballooning to $17 million. That's the equivalent of about $620 million today in terms of. a construction project. So he doesn't have anything like this money. And the way he does it, which you described last time, is TV. He signs a deal with ABC. They will pump cash effectively into his park. And in return, he will make programs, 26 programs a year for them. And this is,
作为现代美国保守主义形成的培养皿。总之，华特·迪士尼决定在这里建立他的公园。他在阿纳海姆买了160英亩的橘子林，他说，好吧，现在我们必须为此买单。现在，迪士尼乐园的预算最终膨胀到1700万美元。按今天的建筑项目计算，这相当于大约6.2亿美元。所以他根本没有这么多钱。他这样做的方式，你上次描述过，是电视。他与ABC签署了一项协议。他们将有效地向他的公园注入现金。作为回报，他将为他们制作节目，每年26个节目。这是，
as you said before, it's the first time a Hollywood studio, rather than seeing television as the enemy, has got into bed with them. And that show, Disneyland, which is the first show. It's a brilliant advert for his new park. And it's a colossal, colossal hit. The only show on TV that is more popular than its repeats is I Love Lucy, the Lucille Ball sitcom. And as you described last time, this is the show that makes Walt himself a public personality. So people get to see kind of Uncle Walt. Now, meanwhile, his team are racing to finish this park.
正如你之前所说，这是好莱坞工作室第一次没有将电视视为敌人，而是与他们同床共枕。而那个节目，迪士尼乐园，是第一个节目。这是对他新公园的一个精彩广告。而且它是一个巨大的、巨大的成功。电视上唯一比其重播更受欢迎的节目是《我爱露西》，露西尔·鲍尔的情景喜剧。正如你上次描述的那样，这个节目让华特本人成为了一个公众人物。所以人们可以看到华特叔叔。现在，与此同时，他的团队正在竞相完成这个公园。
And the timescale is bonkers by modern standards. So they broke ground on the 17th of July, 1954. And Walt basically said to them, I think a year should do it. Wow. You know, you've got 365 days. Loads of problems. They're problems with the soil. They have problems with the unions.
按现代标准来看，时间表是疯狂的。所以他们在1954年7月17日破土动工。华特基本上对他们说，我想一年应该够了。哇。你知道，你有365天。很多问题。土壤有问题。工会有问题。
Oh, those pesky unions again. Yeah, he hates the unions. Problems with plumbing, all of this. Walt is always changing his plans. So he's always saying, why don't we put this here? Why don't we build something else here? Well, exactly like Snow White. Yeah.
哦，那些讨厌的工会又来了。是的，他讨厌工会。管道有问题，所有这些。华特总是改变他的计划。所以他总是说，为什么我们不把这个放在这里？为什么我们不在这里建点别的东西？好吧，就像《白雪公主》一样。是的。
Why don't you spend seven months working on an entertaining thing involving teacups? No, I'm not going to have that. Let's cut it. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. We should actually give a shout out to the person who really runs the project, who's ended up being airbrushed from Disney's history. And this was the general director who was called C.V. Wood. And he'd run the study. He'd basically been charged at the Research Institute that did the study that said, do it in Orange County in Anaheim. And he was brilliant at
为什么你不花七个月时间做一个涉及茶杯的娱乐性事情？不，我不会那样做的。让我们砍掉它。是的，完全正确。完全正确。我们实际上应该向真正负责这个项目的人致敬，他最终被从迪士尼的历史中抹去了。这就是被称为C.V.伍德的总导演。他负责了这项研究。他基本上在研究机构负责，该机构进行了研究，说在奥兰治县的阿纳海姆做这件事。他非常擅长
organizing the project, but he fell out with Walt and he was fired. And he was basically erased from Disney's history, which is very sad. Oh, so something that Disney would have had been common with Chris Jeff. Yeah, erasing people from history. That's true. I hadn't thought of that. It's a nice, yeah, the commissar vanishing. So we'll get into later on what the design of Disneyland is and what it kind of means.
组织这个项目，但他和华特闹翻了，被解雇了。他基本上被从迪士尼的历史中抹去了，这非常令人难过。哦，所以迪士尼和克里斯·杰夫会有共同点。是的，把人从历史中抹去。那是真的。我没想到这一点。这是一个很好的，是的，政委消失了。所以我们稍后会讨论迪士尼乐园的设计是什么，以及它意味着什么。
But some of the themes of its history are there from the very beginning. So first of all, Walt is always really clear that it is not just an amusement park. It's basically a theme park. And the difference is, if you go to an amusement park and you don't go on any rides, you know, you're in for a very boring time because there's nothing else to do. Whereas, as we know, having been, you can go to Disneyland and actually spend the day without going on a single ride. Because you can see all the other attractions. You can go to the shops.
但其历史的一些主题从一开始就在那里。所以首先，华特总是非常清楚，它不仅仅是一个游乐园。它基本上是一个主题公园。区别在于，如果你去一个游乐园，你不去坐任何游乐设施，你知道，你会度过一段非常无聊的时光，因为没有别的事情可做。而正如我们所知，去过之后，你可以去迪士尼乐园，实际上花一天时间而不去坐任何游乐设施。因为你可以看到所有其他景点。你可以去商店。
You can go to the cafes. You can just relax and enjoy yourself. There's parades. There's fireworks. So we went to the Star Wars area, didn't we? And there was a bar like the one in Star Wars. And we were entertained by watching Theo be arrested by a couple of stormtroopers. Exactly.
你可以去咖啡馆。你可以放松并享受自己。有游行。有烟花。所以我们去了星球大战区，不是吗？有一个像星球大战里的酒吧。我们通过观看西奥被几个冲锋队员逮捕而感到娱乐。没错。
Which I thought was actually for me, the single best moment in the whole visit. And the whole of the history, the rest of history, no? And actually, we will return to that moment in a second. Excellent. So it's a land. It's place unto itself in a way that Vauxhall and Tivoli never were. And it's immersive. So every detail has to be right.
这对我来说，实际上是整个访问中最好的时刻。整个历史，历史的其余部分，不是吗？事实上，我们稍后会回到那一刻。太棒了。所以它是一个乐园。它是一个自成一体的地方，沃克斯豪尔和蒂沃利从未有过。而且它是沉浸式的。所以每一个细节都必须正确。
You know, there's an argument at one point where they're going to use cut glass or stained glass. Stain glass, obviously. Yeah, and Walt says it's got to be stained glass. Every detail has to be perfect. Who cares how much it costs? So that's what partly explains the commercialism that we associate with Disney and Disneyland. So the sponsorship, for example, he's got sponsorship deals with American Motors with Richfield Oil with a swift meatpacking company because he needs to pay for all of this
你知道，有一次争论，他们要用切割玻璃还是彩色玻璃。显然是彩色玻璃。是的，华特说必须是彩色玻璃。每一个细节都必须完美。谁在乎它花多少钱？所以这部分解释了我们与迪士尼和迪士尼乐园联系在一起的商业主义。所以赞助，例如，他有与美国汽车公司、里奇菲尔德石油公司、斯威夫特肉类包装公司的赞助协议，因为他需要支付所有这些
attention to detail. And who's he going to get to work in this? Well, this is crucial. So I think this is one of the most inspired things actually about Disneyland. Walt Disney said, you know, this is not just a park. I want people to think of this as a movie set, which we'll get onto later. And so the staff are not employees, they are cast members. And that term is still used entirely unironically by Disney today.
对细节的关注。他要找谁来做这个？好吧，这很关键。所以我认为这是关于迪士尼乐园最受启发的事情之一。华特·迪士尼说，你知道，这不仅仅是一个公园。我希望人们认为这是一个电影布景，我们稍后会讨论。所以员工不是雇员，他们是演员。这个词今天仍然被迪士尼完全不带讽刺意味地使用。
Yeah, so we saw Mary Poppins when we're walking around, but also famously there's Mickey Mouse and Theo's friend, Goofy, and all these kind of characters. Yeah, and the Stormtroopers or whatever. So they're obviously actors, but all the kind of the people who are there to help, they are cast as actors as well. Exactly. And they are playing a part as well in a way because they have to be perfectly turned out. They're all smiling. They're incredibly polite. There's a very strict dress code. And no facial hair. That's the mad thing because Walt has a mustache. And also there's no smoking.
是的，所以我们走来走去时看到了玛丽·波平斯，还有著名的米老鼠和西奥的朋友，高飞，以及所有这些角色。是的，还有冲锋队员什么的。所以他们显然是演员，但所有那些在那里提供帮助的人，他们也被当作演员。没错。而且他们也在扮演一个角色，因为他们必须表现得完美。他们都在微笑。他们非常有礼貌。有一个非常严格的着装要求。而且没有面部毛发。这就是疯狂的事情，因为华特有胡子。而且也没有吸烟。
And if there's one thing everyone knows about Disney, he loves a cigarette. Yeah. And also, no fat people. So the very first manager of Adventureland, which is part of the park. You said later, what was always really mean to me and basically made it very clear that he didn't really want me in his park because I was so large. doesn't like fat guys. So the other thing is the slight suspicion that's hung over Disneyland is did they all have to be white? And that's not really true. So Walt Disney had always employed Asian American artists and illustrators.
如果每个人都知道关于迪士尼的一件事，那就是他喜欢香烟。是的。而且，没有胖子。所以冒险乐园的第一个经理，那是公园的一部分。你后来问，华特总是对我真的很刻薄，基本上很清楚地表明他并不真的想让我进入他的公园，因为我太胖了。不喜欢胖子。所以另一件事是笼罩在迪士尼乐园上的轻微怀疑是他们都必须是白人吗？这并不完全正确。所以华特·迪士尼一直雇佣亚裔美国艺术家和插画家。
But that said, as late as 1963, so civil rights groups are still petitioning the Disney organization and saying to them, can you please guarantee that there will be more black employees. And the Disney organization said, yeah, we'll think about it. But it's actually not clear whether that really had an impact and actually how much changed and how long it took. Anyway, back to the story. The big day approaches the 17th of July, massive excitement. Walt has been promoting it on ABC. ABC themselves have taken out expensive full-page adverts in the newspapers. Right up to the deadline, Walt is tinkering with his park. Of course he is. He's riding the train is saying the shops need to be different and all this kind of thing.
但话虽如此，直到1963年，民权组织仍在向迪士尼组织请愿，并对他们说，你们能保证会有更多的黑人员工吗？迪士尼组织说，是的，我们会考虑的。但实际上并不清楚这是否真的产生了影响，以及实际上改变了多少，花了多长时间。总之，回到故事。大日子临近了，7月17日，巨大的兴奋。华特一直在ABC上宣传它。ABC自己也在报纸上刊登了昂贵的整版广告。直到最后期限，华特还在修补他的公园。当然他是。他坐火车说商店需要不同，所有这些事情。
Four days early, he has his 30th wedding anniversary, and he uses that as a very, very soft opening. He invites his closest friends and some big Hollywood stars like Carrie Grant and Gary Cooper to a party at the Golden Horseshoe Saloon, which is still there, actually. And then 17th of July, the big day dawns. And the funny thing about it is that in many ways, it's total and utter chaos. So first of all, C.V. Wood has sent out 15,000 invitations because it's invitation only. But loads of people print out counterfeit, fake invitations, and get in. And loads of other people basically lean ladders against the fence climb over the ladder to get in,
提前四天，他结婚30周年纪念日，他利用那个作为一个非常、非常软的开幕。他邀请了他最亲密的朋友和一些好莱坞大明星，如加里·格兰特和加里·库珀，到金马蹄沙龙参加派对，那里实际上还在。然后7月17日，大日子到来了。有趣的是，在许多方面，它是完全和彻底的混乱。所以首先，C.V.伍德发出了15,000份邀请，因为它是仅限邀请。但很多人打印出伪造的、假的邀请函，并进去了。还有很多人基本上把梯子靠在栅栏上爬过梯子进去，
much like people used to do at rock festivals and things. There's a heat wave in Southern California, so the temperature hits 101 degrees Fahrenheit. Wasn't there some issue with the water supply? And Walt had to choose between flushing toilets and fountains. And he opts for the toilets, I think, correctly. But then people complain, and they say the water fountains aren't really working because there's been a plumbing strike.
就像人们过去在摇滚音乐节上做的那样。南加州有热浪，所以温度达到了101华氏度。供水不是有问题吗？华特必须在冲厕所和喷泉之间做出选择。我想他选择了厕所，这是正确的。但后来人们抱怨，他们说喷泉并没有真正工作，因为有管道罢工。
Oh, it has unions again. Pesky unions. There's a gas leak. The refreshment stands run out of food and drink. Famously, the newly laid asphalt, the tarmac, melts. So people's, if you're wearing high heels, they get stuck, which is very funny. The TV broadcast, which is watched by a colossal number of people, Neil Gabler, record. and 70 million Americans.
哦，又是那些讨厌的工会。讨厌的工会。有煤气泄漏。茶点摊位食物和饮料用完了。众所周知，新铺的沥青，柏油，融化了。所以人们的，如果你穿高跟鞋，它们会被卡住，这非常有趣。电视广播，被大量的人观看，尼尔·加布勒，记录。和7000万美国人。
The TV broadcast is a bit of a disaster. Ronald Reagan is one of the three presenters. Yeah. Well, Reagan introduces Disney when he makes that thing with which we open this section. Yeah. Yeah.
电视广播有点灾难。罗纳德·里根是三位主持人之一。是的。好吧，里根在做我们开始这一节的事情时介绍了迪士尼。是的。是的。
And now Walt Disney will step forward to read the dedication of Disneyland. So Ronald Reagan is very Disney in his appeal, isn't he, in his ethos? So Disney. He misses his line, forgets his lines, it all goes horribly wrong.
现在华特·迪士尼将走上前台阅读迪士尼乐园的献词。所以罗纳德·里根在吸引力上非常迪士尼，不是吗，在他的精神上？所以迪士尼。他错过了他的台词，忘记了他的台词，一切都变得非常糟糕。
However, Walt is absolutely. delighted with the day. Everybody says at the time, you know, he seems so happy. Well, happiness is the word, isn't it? Because in that opening speech, he says, to all who come to this happy place, welcome. Yeah. And that's the essence of it for him. He wants people to be happy. The happiest place on earth. Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. And actually the press coverage, although the, you know, some of the press said there were quite a few, you know, missed cues and things that went wrong, most of the press coverage was pretty admiring and people said, this is an extraordinary place, an extraordinary achievement. And actually, if you look at the stats,
然而，沃尔特对这一天感到非常高兴。当时每个人都说，你知道，他看起来太开心了。嗯，“幸福”这个词很贴切，不是吗？因为在开幕致辞中，他说：“致所有来到这个快乐之地的人，欢迎你们。”是的，这就是他心目中的精髓。他希望人们感到幸福。地球上最快乐的地方。是的。绝对是。事实上，媒体报道虽然有些媒体说有很多失误和出错的地方，但大多数媒体报道还是相当赞赏的，人们说，这是一个非凡的地方，一项非凡的成就。事实上，如果你看看统计数据，
the first week, 160,000 visitors, by mid-August, 1955, so it's been open now for probably a month, it's had half a million. By the end of September, one million. By its first anniversary, so it's been open 12 months, July 1956, 4 million. By the end of 1957, 10 million. And at that point, by the end of 1957, it's been open for 18 months, it is a bigger attraction than, Yellowstone or Yosemite or the Grand Canyon. It is already, after just 18 months, taken its place in the kind of the wonders of the United States, a place that everybody dreams of going. And it's fascinating that all those sites that you listed are parks, their natural wonders.
第一周就有16万游客，到1955年8月中旬，也就是开业大概一个月后，已经有50万人了。到9月底，达到100万。到一周年纪念日，也就是开业12个月后，1956年7月，达到400万。到1957年底，达到1000万。在那时，到1957年底，它已经开放了18个月，它比黄石公园、优胜美地或大峡谷更具吸引力。仅仅18个月后，它就已经在某种程度上跻身于美国的奇迹之列，成为每个人都梦想去的地方。令人着迷的是，你列出的所有那些景点都是公园，是自然奇观。
And of course, the essence of Disneyland is its complete artificiality. Exactly. So we'll get on to just in the final minutes of the episode. It's meaning, but just on Walt Disney himself. he never stopped. He spent day after day at the park. He had this special apartment built here with the fire station. It's kind of pastiche of Gilded Age America,
当然，迪士尼乐园的精髓在于其完全的人工造景。没错。所以我们将在本集的最后几分钟讨论它的意义，但先谈谈沃尔特·迪士尼本人。他从未停歇。他日复一日地待在公园里。他在消防站这里建了一间特别公寓。这是一种镀金时代美国风格的仿制品，
kind of lots of velvet, lots of lace. And he would stand there at the window looking out, and people would see him. And they'd say he often looked kind of visibly moved, even tearful as he watched these crowds. And there's a lantern kept a light there to this day, isn't it? Yeah, exactly. Yeah, they're kind of a very Disney detail.
有很多天鹅绒，有很多蕾丝。他会站在窗边向外看，人们会看到他。他们说他经常看起来明显很感动，甚至在看着这些人群时热泪盈眶。那里至今还点着一盏灯，对吧？是的，没错。是的，这是一种非常迪士尼的细节。
He said to interviewers, you know, it's not finished, It will never be finished. It's a project that, you know, it's a live, breathing thing. He's always thinking of gondolas and monorails and new rides. So of the iconic rides that are still there today, the Tom Sawyer Island, that opened in 1956, the Matterhorn was 1959, and the Pirates of the Caribbean, which inspired the films. So that was the last ride that Disney designed, and it opened in 1967, a year after his death. So he never got to ride on it, Tom, but we have.
他告诉采访者，你知道，它还没有完成，它永远不会完成。这是一个项目，你知道，它是一个鲜活的、有生命的东西。他总是想着缆车、单轨列车和新的游乐设施。所以，今天仍然存在的标志性游乐设施中，汤姆·索亚历险岛于1956年开放，马特洪峰过山车是1959年的，还有启发了电影的加勒比海盗。那是迪士尼设计的最后一个游乐设施，在他去世一年后的1967年开放。所以他从未亲自坐过它，汤姆，但我们坐过。
We did, didn't we? And before the park could actually open. Doesn't get more Walt Disney than that. I don't want to excite people too much, but there may be a piece of content arriving on YouTube that actually shows us riding the Pirates the Caribbean ride. So that would be fun for people to see. Now, I don't want to tantalize people too much,
我们坐过，不是吗？而且是在公园正式开放之前。没有比这更“沃尔特·迪士尼”的了。我不想让大家太兴奋，但YouTube上可能会有一段内容，展示我们乘坐加勒比海盗游乐设施的画面。所以这对大家来说会很有趣。现在，我不想太吊大家的胃口，
but if you look on YouTube tomorrow, so Friday, you will see a thrilling footage of me and Tom and a special guest riding the Pirates of the Caribbean attraction. And wasn't that fun, Tom? Amazing. One of the great moments in your life, surely. It was all about happiness. It was. So by the end of the 50s, Disney's ambitions have got even greater. He's thinking about something even bigger, a city, not just a theme park, a city. And he gets his executives to buy 27,000 acres of land in Florida. And to put that into context, that is an area the size of Manchester, England, an area twice
但如果你明天，也就是周五，在YouTube上查看，你就会看到我和汤姆以及一位特别嘉宾乘坐加勒比海盗景点的精彩片段。那不是很开心吗，汤姆？太棒了。这绝对是你生命中最伟大的时刻之一。这一切都是关于幸福的。确实如此。所以到了50年代末，迪士尼的野心变得更大了。他正在考虑一些更大的东西，一座城市，不仅仅是一个主题公园，而是一座城市。他让他的高管们在佛罗里达州购买了27000英亩的土地。为了说明这一点，这片区域的大小相当于英国的曼彻斯特，面积是
the size of Manhattan. America. Yeah, Manhattan, America. Just to clarify for people who may be geographically confused. For Australian listeners. And that is what becomes Disney World. So his plan for Disney World is, you know, he says, well, I suppose they'll have to have another amusement park.
曼哈顿的两倍。美国。是的，美国的曼哈顿。为了那些地理位置可能感到困惑的人澄清一下。为了澳大利亚的听众。这就是后来成为迪士尼世界的地方。所以他对于迪士尼世界的计划是，你知道，他说，嗯，我想他们还得再建一个游乐园。
But really, my heart isn't in the amusement park. Yeah, because he's moved on now. He's done his amusement park. So now he wants to do his urban planning. He wants a utopian city for his workers. And it will be modelled. Once again, I'm happy to say Disney World, like Disneyland, is essentially British. Because it is modelled on the garden cities of the Edwardian planner, Sir Ebenezer Howard.
但实际上，我的心并不在游乐园上。是的，因为他现在已经向前看了。他已经完成了他的游乐园。所以现在他想做他的城市规划。他想要为他的工人们建造一座乌托邦式的城市。它将被模仿。我很高兴地说，迪士尼世界和迪士尼乐园一样，本质上是英国式的。因为它模仿的是爱德华时代的规划师埃比尼泽·霍华德爵士的田园城市。
So if you want to see an example of Disney World, merely go to Letchworth or Welling Garden City, which are the garden cities based on Howard's ideas because that's what Walt Disney was all about. The Epcot of the home counties. The Epcot of the home counties. So unfortunately for him, he died and then his vision was dialed down and we ended up being dialed down
所以如果你想看迪士尼世界的例子，去莱奇沃思或韦林花园城就行了，它们是基于霍华德理念的田园城市，因为这就是沃尔特·迪士尼所追求的一切。伦敦周边地区的艾波卡特（Epcot）。伦敦周边地区的艾波卡特。所以不幸的是，他去世了，然后他的愿景被缩减了，我们最终被缩减到了
to one of the lands of Disney World, which is Epcot. It's such a shame, isn't it? And then Upcott now, basically it lingered because it was a massive kind of educational world's fair and nobody wanted to really go. They wanted to go on the rides.
迪士尼世界的一个园区，也就是艾波卡特。真是太可惜了，不是吗？然后艾波卡特现在基本上处于停滞状态，因为它是一个巨大的教育性世界博览会，没人真的想去。他们想去玩游乐设施。
So now it does have rides. It has a ratatooie ride, a frozen ride, and a Guardians of the Galaxy ride. So that's much more exciting. Anyway, Disney World is much bigger, but there's always something very special about Disneyland. It has always fascinated postmodern theorists.
所以现在它确实有了游乐设施。它有料理鼠王游乐设施、冰雪奇缘游乐设施和银河护卫队游乐设施。所以这要令人兴奋得多。总之，迪士尼世界要大得多，但迪士尼乐园总有一些非常特别的东西。它一直让后现代主义理论家着迷。
Especially in Europe, isn't it? Yeah. So part of this, I think, is because of its eclecticism, but also because of the emphasis and kind of fantasy and stuff. We kind of basically invents the idea of postmodernism, different architectural styles mingling together. It does. So Umberto Echo.
特别是在欧洲，对吧？是的。所以我认为这部分是因为它的折衷主义，但也因为对幻想之类的强调。它基本上发明了后现代主义的概念，不同的建筑风格融合在一起。确实。所以翁贝托·埃科，
the author of the Name of the Rose, the great Italian sort of postmodernist theorist. He wrote at length about Pirates the Caribbean ride, which we've been on, and the Haunted Mansion Ride, which I think Tabby may have been on. And he said of Disneyland that it was the Sistine Chapel of America, an allegory of the consumer society, a place of absolute iconism, a place of total passivity. Then you have Jean-Baudria. Oh, brilliant.
《玫瑰的名字》的作者，伟大的意大利后现代主义理论家。他详细地写了关于加勒比海盗游乐设施（我们坐过）和幽灵公馆游乐设施（我想塔比可能坐过）的文章。他称迪士尼乐园为美国的西斯廷教堂，消费社会的寓言，一个绝对偶像化的地方，一个完全被动的地方。然后你有让·鲍德里亚。哦，太棒了。
A French philosopher on the rest of history. We love it. Pile in. Let's get Bojo on the show. He said Disneyland is the supreme example of hyper-reality. And the point of Disneyland, he said, basically, with its artifice and its fantasy, it's to trick us into thinking that the rest of America is real. So French.
一位研究历史的法国哲学家。我们喜欢他。加入进来吧。让鲍德里亚上节目吧。他说迪士尼乐园是超真实的终极典范。他说，迪士尼乐园的意义，基本上，凭借其人工造景和幻想，是为了欺骗我们，让我们认为美国其他地方是真实的。太法国了。
So Disneyland is presented as imaginary in order to make us believe that the rest is real, when in fact, all of Los Angeles and the America surrounding it are no longer real, but of the order of the hyper-real and of simulation. and it continues at great length. I'm not entirely persuaded by Baudrear's argument. I think Los Angeles probably is real. And also I'm not persuaded that Disney visitors are passive, as we shall see. It's expressive of, I guess,
所以迪士尼乐园被呈现为虚构的，目的是让我们相信其余部分是真实的，而事实上，整个洛杉矶和它周围的美国已经不再真实，而是属于超真实和模拟的范畴。而且它还在继续深入。我并不完全被鲍德里亚的论点所说服。我认为洛杉矶可能确实是真实的。而且我也不相信迪士尼的游客是被动的，正如我们将要看到的。我想这表达了，
something that's being characteristic of Europeans looking at Disney's films and then of his scene parks for ages, which is a kind of absolute fascination intermingled with a kind of snobbery as well. Yeah, a snobbish contempt. A snobbish contempt, which I think, I certainly don't share myself. Well, you're a man of the people.
欧洲人长期以来看待迪士尼电影及其主题公园的一种特征，这是一种绝对的迷恋，同时也夹杂着一种势利。是的，一种势利的蔑视。一种势利的蔑视，我想，我本人肯定不认同。嗯，你是个平民主义者。
Well, having been to Disney World as a punter, and as a parent and a punter, I have to say, it was an extremely enjoyable holiday, and I heartily recommend it to people. Something that I denied my own children. Yeah, he did. What does that tell you? Hatrens of all is so much more fun.
嗯，作为一个普通游客，作为一个家长和普通游客去过迪士尼世界，我必须说，这是一个非常愉快的假期，我衷心向大家推荐。我曾经拒绝过我自己的孩子。是的，他确实拒绝了。这说明了什么？哈特伦斯（Hatrens）要有趣得多。
What can I say? So just a couple of aspects of Disneyland that struck me on our recent trip. First of all is, if you went as we did, having immersed yourself in the story of Walt Disney, in the biographies of him and so on. When you get there, it's very obvious how much this is based on one man's personal story and one man's personal genius.
我能说什么呢？所以，在我们最近的旅行中，迪士尼乐园有几个方面让我印象深刻。首先，如果你像我们一样，在沉浸于沃尔特·迪士尼的故事、他的传记等等之后去那里。当你到达那里时，很明显这在多大程度上是基于一个人的个人故事和一个人的个人天才。
So as Neil Gabler points out in his biography, when you enter the park, you arrive in kind of Main Street, USA. And this is very obviously an idealised vision of Walt Disney's boyhood in small town, Marcelline, Missouri. And you walk down the main street and you get to Sleeping Beauty's Castle. And that's the kind of architectural embodiment of the fantasy, the idealism, the ambition that's always drawn him on. And then at the castle, you have a choice of paths, different lands.
正如尼尔·加布勒在他的传记中指出的那样，当你进入公园时，你到达了某种“美国小镇大街”。这显然是沃尔特·迪士尼在密苏里州马塞林小镇童年的理想化愿景。你沿着主街走，到达睡美人城堡。那是他一直追求的幻想、理想主义和野心的建筑体现。然后在城堡那里，你有路径的选择，不同的园区。
So it's fantasy land, adventure land, frontier land, tomorrow land. And those are all in their different ways. Hollywood pop cultural genres of the 1940s and 1950s, the Western, the adventure story, the fantasy, the science fiction story and so on. So I think that takes us to the next point, which is that the park is very obviously, as we've already mentioned, a Hollywood film set. A lot of the attractions, even the older attractions, to a way that we don't really notice now, are modelled on films of mid-century America. So the Western saloon is directly copied from a saloon in the Doris Day film, Calamity Jane. The jungle cruise that you can go on is model on the Humphrey Bogart film, The African Queen.
所以有幻想世界、冒险世界、边境世界、明日世界。这些都是以各自不同的方式，20世纪40年代和50年代的好莱坞流行文化类型，西部片、冒险故事、幻想、科幻故事等等。所以我认为这引出了下一点，即正如我们已经提到的，这个公园非常明显是一个好莱坞电影布景。许多景点，即使是较旧的景点，以一种我们现在并没有真正注意到的方式，都是模仿20世纪中叶美国的电影。西部沙龙直接抄袭了多丽丝·戴的电影《灾星珍妮》中的沙龙。你可以乘坐的丛林巡航是模仿亨弗莱·鲍嘉的电影《非洲女王号》。
And the point is, you're meant to feel like you are in a film. So that moment, the greatest moment in the history of the rest is history, when Bob Eager got his staff to tell the stormtroopers to arrest Theo Young Smith for loitering. And the stormtroopers told Theo off and he looked really sheepish and guilty. Well, he was obviously running guns for whatever it is, the resistance. And they say something like to him. say, don't you want to, do you want to get in trouble again? And Theo says very weakly, no.
重点是，你要感觉自己身处电影之中。所以那一刻，在《历史的其余部分》历史上最伟大的时刻，当鲍勃·艾格让他的员工告诉冲锋队逮捕西奥·杨·史密斯，因为他游手好闲。冲锋队训斥了西奥，他看起来真的很羞愧和内疚。嗯，他显然是在为抵抗组织走私武器之类的。他们对他说了一些类似的话。说，你不想再惹麻烦了吗？西奥非常虚弱地说，不。
That was the best thing I'm a freedom fighter. But he lives to fight another day, to be fair. I guess the other thing just to emphasize is, you say it's like being in a film set. You cannot see outside the park. Once you're in the park, you are surrounded by sets. Total immersion. The rides themselves are stories. This will surprise people who haven't been to Disneyland.
那是最好的事情，我是个自由战士。但公平地说，他活下来继续战斗了。我想还要强调的另一件事是，你说这就像身处电影布景中。你看不见公园外面。一旦你进入公园，你就被布景包围了。完全沉浸。游乐设施本身就是故事。这会让没去过迪士尼乐园的人感到惊讶。
The rides are not like the rides are normal parks, especially when you're, do the queue, you know, there's a whole series of kind of tableau. So the rise of the resistance, the Star Wars ride, which we, we didn't do. But the Star Wars ride, for example, that we did, the rise of the resistance, you feel like you're in a story, right? I mean, I remember the thing you're saying to me afterwards, I've always wanted to be in Star Wars and now I am. That's the whole point of the show. The other interesting thing, just as in a film set, they're doing all kinds of tricks with the proportions. So on the main street, the shops on the bottom floor a nine-tenths of normal size.
这些游乐设施不像普通公园里的游乐设施，特别是当你排队时，你知道，有一系列的情景。所以抵抗组织崛起，那个星球大战游乐设施，我们没玩。但我们玩的那个星球大战游乐设施，抵抗组织崛起，你感觉自己身处一个故事中，对吧？我的意思是，我记得你事后对我说，我一直想身处星球大战中，现在我实现了。这就是节目的全部意义所在。另一个有趣的事情是，就像在电影布景中一样，他们在比例上玩弄各种技巧。所以在主街上，底层的商店是正常尺寸的十分之九。
And then as you go up, they are eight-tenths, seven-tenths, and so on and so forth. Now, this was really deliberate. Walt said to his designers, I want it to feel a little bit like you're in a toy, you know, that you have a, I want to heighten the sense of nostalgia because the past always feels smaller and quainter. He says, at one point to his designers, he says, big build, I don't want big buildings. Big buildings are four dictators. big buildings make you feel small. I want people to feel empowered. And when I read that, I had a look at other buildings built at the same time.
然后当你往上走时，它们是十分之八、十分之七，以此类推。现在，这是非常刻意的。沃尔特对他的设计师说，我希望它感觉有点像你在玩具里，你知道，我想要增强怀旧感，因为过去总是感觉更小、更古雅。他在某个时候对他的设计师说，他说，大建筑，我不想要大建筑。大建筑是给独裁者准备的。大建筑让你感觉渺小。我希望人们感到被赋权。当我读到这一点时，我看了看同时期建造的其他建筑。
And as luck would have it, five days after Disneyland, one of the absolute emblematic buildings of the communist block in the Cold War was opened in Warsaw. This was a building called the Palace of Culture and Science. It kind of towered over Warsaw. People said it was Stalin's gift to the people of Poland. The people of Poland hated it. And it wasn't entirely dissimilar in ethos from Disneyland because it had a swimming pool, it had a cinema, it had theaters, it had a museum. It was meant to be a kind of palace of leisure.
碰巧的是，在迪士尼乐园开业五天后，冷战时期共产主义集团的绝对标志性建筑之一在华沙开幕。这是一座名为科学文化宫的建筑。它在华沙上空高耸。人们说这是斯大林送给波兰人民的礼物。波兰人民讨厌它。它的精神与迪士尼乐园并不完全不同，因为它有一个游泳池，有一个电影院，有剧院，有一个博物馆。它本意是成为一种休闲宫殿。
But the effect could not have been more different. So this building, this very Orwellian building, completely dominated the landscape and the sort of cityscape. And it completely dwarfed the individual. You felt intimidated and crushed by it. Disneyland never has that effect on you. No, and so confirming Walt's darker suspicions of Bolsheviks, Dominic. Quite right. Well, you see, this is the other thing.
但效果却截然不同。所以这座建筑，这座非常奥威尔式的建筑，完全主宰了景观和城市面貌。它完全让个人显得渺小。你感到被它恐吓和压垮了。迪士尼乐园从来没有给你那种感觉。不，所以证实了沃尔特对布尔什维克的黑暗怀疑，多米尼克。说得对。嗯，你看，这是另一件事。
Disneyland is nothing, if it's, if not, a heartfelt tribute to American patriotism. So this is the animatronic Abraham Lincoln and all that. Abraham Lincoln. The ethos of Disneyland, I feel, is very Eisenhower era. It's the nostalgic small-town conservatism on one hand, and the sort of innocent faith in the possibilities of the future on the other. And it wears that kind of Eisenhower era Americanism so heavily. So if you go to Tivoli, we've both been to Tivoli, you can go to Tivoli and you can
迪士尼乐园如果不是对美国爱国主义的衷心致敬，那它就什么也不是。所以这就是机械电子的亚伯拉罕·林肯等等。亚伯拉罕·林肯。我觉得迪士尼乐园的精神非常艾森豪威尔时代。它一方面是怀旧的小镇保守主义，另一方面是对未来可能性的那种天真信仰。它非常沉重地承载着那种艾森豪威尔时代的美国精神。所以如果你去蒂沃利，我们都去过蒂沃利，你可以去蒂沃利，然后你就可以
kind of forget you're in Denmark. I mean, I know there's Hans Christian Anderson, but in all other respects, you know, it could be in the Netherlands or in Sweden or in Vauxhall, in Vauxhall, exactly. There is no way you could go to Disneyland in California and doubt that you're in an American creation. I mean, the Americanness is everywhere, almost every ride, even the ones with British themes, you know, reek of American, Americanness, American patriotism and so on. So that's why Peel Travers hated it when Walt took her there. And so to go back one more time to the Cold War era, I think in the smallness, in the individualism and the American patriotism, it's very much a product at that time.
忘记你身处丹麦。我的意思是，我知道有汉斯·克里斯蒂安·安徒生，但在所有其他方面，你知道，它可能在荷兰、瑞典或沃克斯豪尔，就在沃克斯豪尔，没错。你不可能去加利福尼亚的迪士尼乐园而怀疑你身处一个美国的创造物中。我的意思是，美国特色无处不在，几乎每一个游乐设施，即使是那些带有英国主题的，你知道，都散发着美国味、美国特色、美国爱国主义等等。所以这就是为什么皮·特拉弗斯在沃尔特带她去那里时讨厌它。所以再回到冷战时代，我认为在那种渺小、个人主义和美国爱国主义中，它非常是那个时代的产品。
But there's also the sense of order and harmony and reassurance that I think reflects. the values of the day as well. So to compare it once again with Vauxhall, the Vauxhall Pleasure Gardens in the 18th and 19th century, the organisers tried to keep kind of disorder and the lower orders obey by charging a shilling and later three shillings. But there was always a suspicion that kind of, you know,
但也有那种秩序、和谐和令人安心的感觉，我认为这也反映了当时的价值观。所以再次与沃克斯豪尔相比，18和19世纪的沃克斯豪尔游乐花园，组织者试图通过收取一先令，后来是三先令来保持某种秩序和下层阶级的服从。但总有一种怀疑，你知道，
reality was breaking in. You know, there were darken corners where people were drinking or they were sneaking off for erotic assignations. There was always the possibility of hedonism, and unrulyness. And that's true, I think, with a lot of parks, gaggles of teenagers who've been, you know, necking gin or something. Well, it's why, I suppose, when Euro-Disney opens,
现实正在闯入。你知道，有黑暗的角落，人们在那里喝酒，或者他们溜出去进行色情约会。总是有享乐主义和不守规矩的可能性。我认为这对于很多公园来说都是真的，一群群喝了杜松子酒之类的青少年。嗯，我想这就是为什么当欧洲迪士尼开业时，
there's no alcohol on sale, because that has to be guarded against. Right. Your wholesomeness. Yeah. I mean, Coney Island, Blackpool Pleasure Beach, those are places where you go and you have fun, and there's always a suspicion that nautinus may ensue. Nortiness may ensue.
没有酒精出售，因为必须防范这一点。对。你的纯洁性。是的。我的意思是，康尼岛、布莱克浦游乐海滩，那些是你去玩乐的地方，总有一种怀疑，可能会发生淘气的事情。可能会发生淘气的事情。
That's never going to happen at Disneyland. So the future American ambassador to Britain, Nixon's ambassador to Britain, Walter Annenberg, who was a publisher, when he went to Disneyland, he said, if there's one word that sums it up, that word is wholesomeness. And he's not wrong. So, for example, the cleanniness is a huge part of Disneyland's ethos. Walt Disney used to go around picking up litter himself. And actually, when we were there, Tom, I noticed, out of the corner of my eye, Bob Iger, the head of Disney, stop. reaching into the kind of gutter or something and picking up, you know, a bit of litter and putting it in the bin. You know, this sort of almost as an instinctive kind of
这在迪士尼乐园永远不会发生。所以未来的美国驻英国大使，尼克松的驻英大使沃尔特·安嫩伯格，他是一位出版商，当他去迪士尼乐园时，他说，如果有一个词能概括它，那个词就是“纯洁”。他没说错。所以，例如，清洁是迪士尼乐园精神的很大一部分。沃尔特·迪士尼过去常常亲自去捡垃圾。事实上，当我们去那里时，汤姆，我注意到，在我的眼角余光里，迪士尼的负责人鲍勃·艾格停了下来。伸手去够排水沟之类的东西，捡起一点垃圾，把它放进垃圾桶。你知道，这几乎是一种本能的
reflex. And I think what that reflects is that there is an ethos of total order. Nothing unexpected can ever happen at Disneyland. You know, people always say, if you're ever going to lose your child, lose your child at Disneyland because there's absolutely no way that anything bad can happen and you know your child will be returned to you. And that, of course, is what more high-brow critics always dislike it because high-brow critics tend to like disorder. You know, they kind of privilege unrulyness and hedonism and all those kinds of things. And they find Disneyland too managed and too perfect. But of course, that's what ordinary punters like about it.
反射。我认为这反映了存在一种完全秩序的精神。在迪士尼乐园永远不会发生任何意想不到的事情。你知道，人们总是说，如果你要弄丢你的孩子，就在迪士尼乐园弄丢，因为绝对不可能发生任何坏事，而且你知道你的孩子会被送回给你。当然，这就是那些高雅的评论家总是讨厌它的原因，因为高雅的评论家倾向于喜欢混乱。你知道，他们倾向于赋予不守规矩、享乐主义和所有这些事情特权。他们觉得迪士尼乐园管理得太严、太完美了。但当然，这就是普通游客喜欢它的地方。
There's a collection of essays by somebody called Carol Ann Marling. And she talks about the Disney parks. She says it's the architecture of reassurance. You know, there's no writh angles. it's all loops, it's all kind of curves. Like Mickey's ears. Yeah, like Mickie's ears, exactly. It all feels kind of comforting.
有一个叫卡罗尔·安·马林的人写了一系列文章。她谈到了迪士尼公园。她说这是“令人安心的建筑”。你知道，没有锐角，全是圆环，全是曲线。就像米奇的耳朵。是的，就像米奇的耳朵，没错。这一切感觉都很令人欣慰。
It feels like there is a gentle, sort of paternalistic order that is governing everything. And some people find that cloying and off-putting, but frankly, if you go there with an eight-year-old or something, you absolutely crave. Maybe you don't because you take them to Adrian's Wall where they look miserable in the rain. But I loved going to Disney World as a parent.
感觉有一种温和的、某种家长式的秩序在管理着一切。有些人觉得这令人作呕和反感，但坦率地说，如果你带着一个八岁的孩子去那里，你绝对会渴望这种感觉。也许你不会，因为你带他们去哈德良长城，他们在雨中看起来很痛苦。但我喜欢作为家长去迪士尼世界。
Because I thought it's the one place where I could kind of switch off and know that nothing would ever possibly go wrong. Well, it is, again, that idea of total control also requires banishment of things that might threaten that control. So there's the slogan isn't that when you enter Disneyland, you will find yourself in the land of yesterday, tomorrow and fantasy. Nothing of the present exists in Disneyland. And so you're escaping the news. You're escaping the chaos of the headlines and all of that. And I assume that that is why it's been a kind of perennial theme of science fiction since Disneyland opened to imagine what would happen if a theme park goes wrong. So in 1973, the novelist Michael Crichton wrote a script for a film called Westworld, which was set in a Western theme park.
因为我想这是唯一一个我可以放松下来，并且知道绝对不会出任何差错的地方。嗯，这又是那种完全控制的想法，也需要驱逐那些可能威胁到这种控制的东西。所以不是有那个口号吗，当你进入迪士尼乐园时，你会发现自己身处昨天、明天和幻想的土地。在迪士尼乐园里不存在任何当下的东西。所以你在逃避新闻。你在逃避头条新闻的混乱和所有这些。我假设这就是为什么自从迪士尼乐园开业以来，想象主题公园出错一直是科幻小说的一种永恒主题。所以1973年，小说家迈克尔·克莱顿写了一个名为《西部世界》的电影剧本，背景设定在一个西部主题公园。
And you have animatronic gunslingers, and one of them is played by your brinner. And it all goes wrong. Gonslingers start shooting the guests. And then, of course, in 1990, Michael Crichton published another book on a similar theme called Jurassic Park, which was then made into the film by Stephen Spielberg. And I have to say, we got taken by Bob Iger behind the scenes at Disney World, which I thought, in a way, was the kind of the biggest privilege I felt going there because you get to see what normal visitors don't see. And I have to say that walking behind, you know, the Star Wars ride or whatever down these gantries and ladders and things. The whole time I was waiting for a velociraptor to leap out of a tree and attack us. Yeah.
你有机械电子的枪手，其中一个由尤·伯连纳扮演。然后一切都出错了。枪手开始射击游客。然后，当然，1990年，迈克尔·克莱顿出版了另一本关于类似主题的书，名为《侏罗纪公园》，后来被斯蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格拍成了电影。我必须说，鲍勃·艾格带我们去了迪士尼世界的幕后，我认为在某种程度上，这是我去那里感受到的最大的特权，因为你可以看到普通游客看不到的东西。我必须说，走在星球大战游乐设施后面，或者沿着这些龙门架和梯子之类的东西走。我一直在等待一只迅猛龙从树丛中跳出来攻击我们。是的。
Surely you're waiting for that the whole time, though, aren't you? Whether you're at Disneyland or not. I think it felt very Jurassic Park behind the scenes. Yeah. But the difference is that you know that's not going to happen at Disneyland because it's basically the ultimate safe space, isn't it? Correct. Now, some people, I think, will find that a hellish prospect.
你肯定一直在等那个，对吧？无论你是否在迪士尼乐园。我认为幕后感觉非常像《侏罗纪公园》。是的。但区别在于你知道在迪士尼乐园不会发生那种事，因为它基本上是终极的安全空间，不是吗？正确。现在，我认为有些人会觉得这是一个地狱般的前景。
Frankly, I think those people have got no souls. Because I love Disneyland. And I say that, you know, even before I'd gone with Bob. And actually, I think this is the most enduring thing that Disney created, even more than the films. Because I know the films are great. Snow White is a great film, a landmark in Hollywood filmmaking. But not that many people watch those films today. They're period pieces.
坦率地说，我认为这些人没有灵魂。因为我喜欢迪士尼乐园。我这么说，你知道，甚至在我去见鲍勃之前。事实上，我认为这是迪士尼创造的最持久的东西，甚至超过了电影。因为我知道电影很棒。《白雪公主》是一部伟大的电影，是好莱坞电影制作的一个里程碑。但今天没那么多人看那些电影了。它们是时代作品。
They are, but they do establish the kind of the animated tradition, which is, you know, frozen and all of that. I don't disagree with you at all. But millions of people visit the parks as living, kind of breathing things. Probably billions of people have children who watch films with Disney films on video. And they have been enormously influential architecturally. So as early as 1963, at a conference at Harvard, a developer called James Rouse, who was actually the father of the modern shopping mall, he addressed his audience who were architects and critics. He said to them, you know, you may be shocked by this, but my view is that the greatest piece of urban. design in the United States today is Disneyland. In its respect for people, in its functioning
它们确实是，但它们确实确立了动画传统，也就是《冰雪奇缘》等等。我一点也不反对你。但数以百万计的人将这些公园视为鲜活的、有生命的东西。可能有数十亿人的孩子在视频上观看迪士尼电影。它们在建筑上影响巨大。所以早在1963年，在哈佛的一次会议上，一位名叫詹姆斯·劳斯的开发商，他实际上是现代购物中心的鼻祖，他向他的听众（建筑师和评论家）发表了演讲。他对他们说，你知道，你们可能会对此感到震惊，但我的观点是，当今美国最伟大的城市设计作品是迪士尼乐园。在尊重人、为
for people, Disneyland has more to teach modern planners than any other single piece of physical development in this country. Well, just to reiterate, it has no cars. I mean, I think that's absolutely crucial to it. Yeah. It's what American tourists are Europe like when they go to Looker or Florence or whatever. Yeah, that's true. And it's also what they like when they go to Disneyland, that you do actually have to walk. I'm amazed American urban planners don't kind of factor that in a little bit more. Well, I think it's because it's on a human scale. I'll give the last word to a guy like Robert Venturi.
人服务方面，迪士尼乐园比这个国家任何其他单一的物理开发项目有更多东西可以教给现代规划者。嗯，重申一下，它没有汽车。我的意思是，我认为这对它来说绝对至关重要。是的。这就是美国游客去卢浮宫或佛罗伦萨等地时喜欢的东西。是的，那是真的。这也是他们去迪士尼乐园时喜欢的东西，你确实必须走路。我很惊讶美国城市规划者没有更多地考虑到这一点。嗯，我想这是因为它是在人类尺度上的。我把最后的话留给罗伯特·文丘里这样的人。
So he's the massively influential postmodern architect. And he designed the Sainsbury Wing of the National Gallery in London. He was a massive fan of Disney's parks. And he argued that Disney parks were the ultimate expression of the kind of city on a hill, American utopian impulse. And he said, the best thing about Disney's parks was that they have come nearer to what people really want than anything that architects have ever given them. Well, on that lordatory tone, thank you, Dominic, that was fantastic. And coming out tomorrow, as you mentioned
所以他是极具影响力的后现代建筑师。他设计了伦敦国家美术馆的塞恩斯伯里翼楼。他是迪士尼公园的超级粉丝。他认为迪士尼公园是美国乌托邦冲动中“山巅之城”的终极表达。他说，迪士尼公园最棒的地方在于，它们比建筑师给他们的任何东西都更接近人们真正想要的东西。嗯，带着那种赞美的语气，谢谢你，多米尼克，那太棒了。明天就要播出了，正如你提到的
Dominic, an extra special treat for our beloved listeners that may well feature Dominic going on the Pirates of the Caribbean ride. I don't know, because I haven't actually seen the film yet, but it'll be very, very good, very entertaining, I think. Thank you so much. much. Next week, we have one additional Disney bonus. We will be going back to the great films. We'll be placing them in the context of the age that produced them. So that is Snow White through to Bambi. So I hope you enjoy that. And next week, we are going back in time to the young Elizabeth, the girl who will grow up to become Elizabeth I, her adventures, her scrapes with danger before she became queen.
多米尼克，为我们敬爱的听众准备了一份特别的款待，其中可能包括多米尼克去坐加勒比海盗游乐设施。我不知道，因为我还没看过那段视频，但我认为它会非常非常棒，非常有趣。非常感谢。下周，我们还有一个额外的迪士尼奖励。我们将回到伟大的电影。我们将把它们置于产生它们的时代背景中。所以那是从《白雪公主》到《小鹿斑比》。所以我希望你喜欢。下周，我们将回到年轻的伊丽莎白时代，那个成长为伊丽莎白一世的女孩，她的冒险，她在成为女王之前的危险经历。
So we will see you then, I hope. But for now, bye-bye. Bye-bye. Hi there, it's David Olushoge from Journey Through Time. And here's that extract from our gunpowder plot series that I mentioned earlier. The person who's not rejoicing is Guy Fawkes in the tower. King James himself came to the tower to question. that's quite an astonishing fact that forks and the king looked into each other's
所以我希望到时能见到你们。但现在，再见。再见。大家好，我是《穿越时空》的大卫·奥卢索加。这是我之前提到的我们火药阴谋系列中的片段。那个不高兴的人是塔里的盖伊·福克斯。詹姆斯国王亲自来到塔里审问。这是一个相当惊人的事实，福克斯和国王在那一刻对视了
eyes at that moment and of course interrogations at this time I mean we say interrogations as if they're just being questioned but interrogations are brutal violent events yeah and it's going to get much much more violent forks stands up to the king in a way that actually even impresses the king he's open that they plan to blow parliament he said that the aim had been to blow King James and the other Scots back to their Scottish mountains he says that to the king. It takes guts. But it's also not the most diplomatic thing to say to the person you've just tried to murder who, and your fate is in his hands. Yeah. Well, I think Fawkes knows
双眼，当然那个时代的审讯，我的意思是，我们说审讯好像只是被询问，但审讯是残酷、暴力的事件。是的，而且会变得越来越暴力。福克斯以一种甚至让国王印象深刻的方式站出来对抗国王。他公开表示他们计划炸毁议会，他说目标是把詹姆斯国王和其他苏格兰人炸回他们的苏格兰山脉，他当着国王的面这么说。这需要胆量。但这也不是对你刚刚试图谋杀的人最外交的说法，而且你的命运掌握在他手中。是的。嗯，我想福克斯知道
what's going to happen. I mean, the king was impressed by his obstinacy, that he would not reveal the names of his co-conspirators, that he was willing to insult the king to his face. And you have to say about Guy Fawkes, a man who'd been a soldier for 10 years, my God, he had guts. I mean, he is a bad man. He is a religious fanatic. He's not. not somebody I admire, but my God, he was brave. You can be brave and wrong. You can be brave and involved in things that are evil at the same time. And he was all of those things. But this willingness to stand up to the king that this is before the torture. If you want to hear more about gumpowder, treason and plot, listen to Journey Through Time wherever you get your podcasts.
会发生什么。我的意思是，国王对他的固执印象深刻，他不会透露他的同谋者的名字，他愿意当面侮辱国王。你不得不说盖伊·福克斯，一个当了10年兵的人，天哪，他有胆量。我的意思是，他是个坏人。他是个宗教狂热分子。他不是。不是我钦佩的人，但天哪，他很勇敢。你可以勇敢而错误。你可以勇敢，同时参与邪恶的事情。他就是所有这些。但这种站出来对抗国王的意愿，这是在酷刑之前。如果你想听更多关于火药、叛国和阴谋的内容，请在任何你获取播客的地方收听《穿越时空》。
George Orwell was one of the most impactful voices of the 20th century. But do you know what? His life story is just as interesting as the things he wrote. I'm William Drimple. And I'm Anita Arndon. And we are the hosts of Empire, a goalhanger show about world history. And on Empire, we're currently in the middle of a gripping four-part series about the life of George Orwell. Orwell's early life was wrapped up in the British Empire.
乔治·奥威尔是20世纪最有影响力的声音之一。但你知道吗？他的人生故事和他写的东西一样有趣。我是威廉·达尔林普尔。我是安妮塔·阿南德。我们是《帝国》的主持人，这是一个关于世界历史的Goalhanger节目。在《帝国》中，我们目前正在进行一个关于乔治·奥威尔生平的扣人心弦的四部分系列节目。奥威尔的早年生活与大英帝国紧密相连。
in India to an opium trading father, and in his 20s he served as a colonial police officer in Burma. His later life crystallised his hatred of totalitarianism. As an idealistic writer, he travelled to fight with the Republicans against Franco's fascists in the Spanish Civil War, and he witnessed the horrors of the Blitz. These experiences led him to write his most famous novels, Animal Farm and 1984, giving us enduring phrases like Big Brother is watching you. To listen to our miniseries now, subscribe to Empire, wherever you get your podcast. Hello, History Fans, it's Richard Osmond and Marina Hyde here from the rest is entertainment podcast.
在印度，父亲是鸦片贸易商，20多岁时他在缅甸担任殖民警察。他晚年的生活使他对极权主义的仇恨结晶。作为一名理想主义作家，他在西班牙内战中前往与共和党人一起对抗佛朗哥的法西斯分子，并目睹了闪电战的恐怖。这些经历促使他写下了他最著名的小说《动物庄园》和《1984》，为我们留下了像“老大哥在看着你”这样经久不衰的短语。要收听我们的迷你剧，请在任何你获取播客的地方订阅《帝国》。你好，历史迷们，我是理查德·奥斯曼和玛丽娜·海德，来自《其余皆娱乐》播客。
Now, if your group chats buzzing with celebrity traitors fan theories, Alan Carr Gifts and Claudia Winkleman outfit inspiration, then our podcast is the place for you. Every week, we've been reacting to new episodes of the biggest show of the year immediately after they air. And this Thursday's final will be no different. us for a live stream debrief at 10.15 p.m. from the ultimate set of traitors fans, us. Just search the rest is entertainment on YouTube or wherever you get your podcasts. Big dogs only. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在，如果你的群聊里充斥着名人叛徒粉丝理论、艾伦·卡尔的礼物和克劳迪娅·温克尔曼的服装灵感，那么我们的播客就是你的不二之选。每周，我们都会在年度最大节目的新剧集播出后立即做出反应。这个周四的决赛也不会例外。加入我们的直播解说，时间是晚上10点15分，来自终极叛徒粉丝——我们。只需在YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方搜索《其余皆娱乐》。只欢迎大人物。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。